TODAY'S HEARING BEING HELD UP
BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
JOBS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN
THE ECONOMY I AM ASSEMBLY
SABRINA ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES AND I SERVE AS THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE WITH ME
THIS MORNING ARE SEVERAL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES
RAMOS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
I WANTING TO ENSURE THAT- IF
THEY'RE- IN THE OPENING.
INTRODUCTIONS GIVE THEM A FEW
MOMENTS TO SAY A FEW WORDS IF
THEY WISH- BUT I JUST WANTED TO
ALSO. LET YOU ALL KNOW THAT WE
ALSO HAVE RELIGIOUSLY
AFFILIATED POLICY STUFF WITH US
OUR CHIEF CONSULTANT WITH THE
ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE TONY
SIMONS. AND WE ALSO HAVE OUR
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS POLICY
CONSULTANT I MISS GILLIAN.
JOINING US FROM OUR COMMITTEE
OFFICE IS MERCEDES FOR AS
ACTEON COMMITTEE SECRETARY
MERCEDES IS AVAILABLE TO ASSIST
ANYONE WHO MAY BE HAVING
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES ARE ANY
KIND OF PROBLEM CONNECTING WITH
OUR LIVE STREAM. SHE CAN BE
REACHED AT 916-319-2090 BEFORE
WE DO BEGIN THE AGENDA
PRESENTATION I DO WANT TO
PROVIDE A FEW HIGHLIGHTS
OVERVIEW ON HOW THE PUBLIC WILL
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
HEARING. DUE TO SAFETY OF KOBE
NINETEEN PROTOCOLS WE ARE
REQUIRING MASS TO BE WORN ANY
PHYSICAL DISTANCE SEEM TO BE
MAINTAINED BY EVERYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASK WINDS WILL BE
PROVIDED FOR YOU. FOR THOSE
WATCHING THE HEARING WHO WISH
TO SPEAK DURING AN AGENDA ITEM
FIVE WE WILL BE TAKING PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AT THAT TIME AND THE
NUMBER TO CALL WOULD BE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. THIS IS THE
SAME NUMBER THAT CAN BE USED
BY- THE PUBLIC TO FOLLOW THE
HEARING USING YOUR PHONE. THIS
PUBLIC ACCESS NUMBERS ALSO
POSTED ON THE JEDI WEBSITE. WE
DO ANTICIPATE TAKING ITEM
AGENDA ITEM FIVE UP AROUND
ELEVEN FIFTEEN AM. WE HAVE
SCHEDULED UP TO THIRTY MINUTES
OF THE HEARING FOR PUBLIC AND
STAKEHOLDER COMMENTS. LET ME GO
AHEAD AND- JUST FRAME TODAY'S
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. THIS IS
THE SECOND IN A SERIES OF
HEARINGS I AM VERY FAN
SPONSORED BY THE ASSEMBLY JOBS
COMMITTEE THAT WILL EXAMINE
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INCLUSIVE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY TO HELP FRAME
THIS HEARING THAT LET US
REMEMBER THAT RESPONDING TO THE
PANDEMIC HAS REQUIRED THE STATE
TO TAKE EXTREME AND RAPID STEPS
TO PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIANS WITHIN
ONE WEEK IN MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY THE STATE ONE FROM. OPEN
FOR BUSINESS TO IMPLEMENTING A
STRICT STAFF HOME ORDER FOR
EVERYONE NOT DIRECTLY ENGAGED
IN WHAT GOVERNMENT CONSIDERED
AN ESSENTIAL CRITICAL BUSINESS
ACTIVITY. SINCE MARCH TWELFTH
OF TWENTY TWENTY IT HAS BEEN
ESTIMATED THAT MORE THAN
NINETEEN THOUSAND JOBS.
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
SHUTTHEIR DOORS PERMANENTLY
OVER FOURTEEN POINT ONE MILLION
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CLAIMS
HAVE BEEN FILED RESULTING. IN
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. BEING PAID TO
IMPACTED WORKERS CONTRACTORS
AND THEIR PET FAMILIES. WE'VE
ALSO LOST MORE THAN FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS OF WHICH
MORE THAN 66% OF THESE BEING
PEOPLE OF COLOR. MANY OF THEM
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO CONTINUE TO WORK IN
HIGH RISK ENVIRONMENTS IN ORDER
TO KEEP OUR ECONOMY MOVING
FORWARD. WITH THIS INFORMATION
WE HAVE ENGAGED ON KEY ISSUES
INCLUDING PROPOSING A
MANUFACTURING RECOVERY
INITIATIVE TO THE GOVERNOR AND
SETTING CLEAR EXPECTATIONS ON
THE NEED FOR TARGETED OUT
REACH. GREATER TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE
REFUNDING OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
COME BID NINETEEN RELIEF GRAPH.
MY INTENTION IN INITIATING THE
SERIES OF HEARINGS IS TO CREATE
A PUBLIC PLATFORM BY WHICH THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE. JOBS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CAN HEAR FROM
STAKEHOLDERS TRACK QUALITY
RESEARCH AND MAKE FURTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE RECOVERY
PROPOSALS WITHIN OUR POLICY
AREAS. ARE COMMITTEE PACKAGE IS
OUR STARTING PLACE AND SO I
WILL HIGHLIGHT FOR BILLS FOR
YOU AND THAT IS AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY ONE THE REGULATORY
FAIRNESS ACT. AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY TWO THE CALIFORNIA NEW
MARKET TAX CREDITS. IN AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE THE
BUSINESS RETENTION PROGRAM AND
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESS NDV BE
CONTRACTING ACT. WE HAVE SEEN
FIRST HAND WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THE NEEDS OF CERTAIN PEOPLE ARE
PLACED IN PLACES ARE EXCLUDED
INCLUDING LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS. RURAL
COMMUNITIES MINORITIES VETERANS
AND WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES. SO
TO HELP GET THESE ISSUES GET
OUT THESE ISSUES WE HAVE
ORGANIZED A HEARING INTO FOUR
PARTS THE FIRST IS. THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. HE WILL BE
GIVING US- SHERRY NEW FRAMEWORK
THAT THEY HAVE DEVELOPER VALLEY
WAITING STATE ECONOMIC STIMULUS
PROPOSALS. THAT DOES INCLUDE AN
IMPORTANT ASSESSMENT REGARDING
EQUITY. SECONDS WE WILL HEAR
FROM TIM RAINY THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
THIRD WE HAVE SCHEDULED A PANEL
BUSINESSES AND LABOR LEADERS
WHO WILL BE SHARING THEIR
PRIORITIES- IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FOR AN INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND FOURTH WE WILL
HAVE A PUBLIC TESTIMONY AND AT
THIS POINT WE DO ENCOURAGE
STAKEHOLDERS TO SHOW THEIR
PRIORITIES IN WRITING AS WELL
AS BRIEFLY OUTLINING THE
RECOVERY. OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD. SO I BELIEVE. MADAM
SECRETARY IF WE CAN ESTABLISH
QUORUM. THANK YOU
CHARACTERIZING HERE. YOUR
DEVELOPING HERE BY FEAR
CUNNINGHAM. ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
BOERNER HORVATH HERE
BOERNER HORVATH HERE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CAP ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATRICK ALL RIGHT HERE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FACTORY NORTH HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OUT OF HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SPENT HERE
YEAH. YOU HAVE A WARRANT. THANK
YOU MISS SIMON'S. SO GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON- I WANT TO GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO OFFER ANY
OPENING REMARKS. AT THIS POINT
SEEN NINE ARE WE CAN GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON TO AGENDA ITEM TO.
OUR FIRST SPEAKER I'VE WE CAN
BEGAN- BY OPENING HIS AUDIO
VIDEO SETTING. FOR OUR ASSEMBLY
TECHNICIANS I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THERE IS A POWER POINT
PRESENTATION ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS OUR PORTION. I'M HERE MY
ERROR. LOL NOTHING. LIKE THAT
SO WE ARE NOT AT IT BUT WE DO
NOT HAVE POWER POINT
PRESENTATION FOR THIS AGENDA
ITEMS LET ME GO AHEAD AND
INTRODUCE MISTER BRYANT YOU
ALERT DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST WITH THE OFFICE AS A
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST HE DOES
COVER A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT
DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY. THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
THE FINANCING AUTHORITIES
WITHIN THE TREASURER'S OFFICE
MOST RECENTLY THE L. A. O.
RELEASED A FRAMEWORK FOR
EVALUATING THE STATE ECONOMIC
STIMULUS PROPOSALS- THAT DOES
EMPHASIZE TIME WHEN. TIMELY
MESSED HER JEAN AND ENSURING
THAT RECOVERY ACTIONS DO NOT
INADVERTENTLY EXASPERATED
PREEXISTING INEQUITIES. I
MISTER YOU ARE HAS BEEN USING
THIS FRAMEWORK IN DISCUSSING
KEY ELEMENTS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLAR ECONOMIC RECOVERY
PACKAGE AS WELL AS PROVIDING.
PROVIDING US WITH THE
PRELIMINARY LOOK AT HOW THE ONE
POINT NINE TRILLION DOLLAR
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN AND
THEY'RE- SUPPOSED TO TRILLION
DOLLAR FEDERAL SIMON MITIGATION
AND PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN
COULD BE LEVERAGE FOR A MORE
INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN
CALIFORNIA. MISTER YOU ARE ON
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
FOR JOINING. US THIS MORNING
HIS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF.
THANK FOR HAVING OUR OFFICE OF
HER JUST IN THIS AREA TODAY-
YOU KNOW THE DRAMATIC AG DOWN
FOR BY THE NINE AND IS PROMPTED
AS YOU MENTIONED A VARIETY OF
FEDERAL AND STATE A PROPOSALS
AIMED AT PROMOTING ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. I NEVER RESPONSE TO-
THESE PROPOSALS ARE OFFICE TO
DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO EVALUATE- THESE
VARIOUS ACTIONS. MY
PRESENTATION TODAY I WILL
SUMMARIZE OUR AND THEN APPLY IT
TO SOME PAUL AND A FEW ERROR-
ARE FRAMEWORK GENERALLY IS A SO
OF. WE THAT'S HELP FOR THOSE.
TO ASK. ABOUT PROPOSAL IN AT.
RISK THE FOR TWO QUESTIONS ARE
MORE BY THE FACT THAT UNLIKE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHICH
CAN FUND ECONOMIC STIMULUS
THROUGH DEFICIT SPENDING. ANY
STATE SPENDING ON AN ACTIVITY
OR PROJECT COMES AT THE DIRECT
COST OF REDUCE STATE SPENDING
ON OTHER ACTIVITIES. AND THESE
ARE SENDING REDUCTIONS CAN MAKE
IT HARD TO ASSUME THAT ANY
STATE SPENDING. AIMED AT
GROWING THE ECONOMY WILL
ULTIMATELY ACHIEVE ITS GOAL.
FOR THIS REASON THERE IS A HIGH
NEED FOR THE STATE TO GET THE
BEST BANG FOR ITS BUCK IF YOU
WILL AND SO TO DO SO WOULD BE
SUGGEST. ASKING A FEW
QUESTIONS- FIRST ASSEMBLY DOES
THE STATE SPENDING TARGET THE
PEOPLE AND BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
BEEN MOST IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC. A MASS WHY WHAT'S THE
RATIONALE FOR THIS FOCUS OVER
SAY A FOCUSING ON BOOSTING
CONSERVE MATERIALS AND
GENERALLY OR- PROMOTING A
CERTAIN- STRATEGICALLY
IMPORTANT SECTOR OF THE OF THE
STATE LET ME. GIVE YOU A FEW
REASONS- FIRST- MANY WORKERS
AND BUSINESS OWNERS THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC.
HAVE INVESTED A LOT OF TIME AND
RESOURCES INTO BUILDING A TRADE
OR BUSINESS. AND THEY COULD
FACE SIGNIFICANT COSTS- IF
THERE WILL TYPICALLY FORCE TO
TRANSITION INTO A NEW
OCCUPATION OR NEW SECTOR AS A
RESULT. OF THE PANDEMIC. AND SO
BECAUSE OF THIS- HELPING
BUSINESS OWNERS AND WORKERS WHO
HAVE BEEN DISPLACED BY THE
PANDEMIC RESUME THEIR PRIOR
ROLES MAYBE THE QUICKEST WAY TO
GET THEM BACK TO WORK IN MANY
CASES- SECOND. UNLIKE PAST
RECESSIONS WHICH REMARK BY A
MAJOR STRUCTURAL SHIFTS IN THE
ECONOMY THINK- THE AEROSPACE
AND DEFENSE CUTBACKS IN THE
EARLY NINETIES OR THE REAL
THING FINANCING TRACTION DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION. RIGHT NOW
IT'S TOO EARLY TO TELL WHETHER
THE CURRENT ECONOMIC DOWNTURN
WILL LEAD TO PERMANENT LONG
TERM CHANGES IN THE STATE'S
ECONOMY- OR WHETHER THE
SLOWDOWN HAS BEEN- MORE
TRANSITORY RESPONSE. TO THE
EMERGENCY OF THE PANDEMIC. THE
STATE MAY ULTIMATELY SEE
STRUCTURAL SHIFTS AS A RESULT
OF THE PANDEMIC BUT AT THE
MOMENT ANY ATTEMPT TO GAUGE
WHERE THE SHIPS MIGHT OCCUR-
WILL JUST BE GUESSES ARE WITH
LITTLE HISTORICAL PRECEDENT TO
DRAW ON- FINALLY THE DATA WE
HAVE ON BUSINESS TRENDS DURING
THE PANDEMIC- SUGGESTS THAT NEW
BUSINESS FORMATION IN
CALIFORNIA. HAS ACTUALLY
QUICKLY SNAPPED BACK TO PRE
PANDEMIC LEVELS. AND IN
ADDITION WE SEE THAT DURING
TWENTY TWENTY. BUSINESS
FORMATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO EXCEED NATIONAL
ARMS AND FOR ALL THESE REASONS
WITH YOU KNOW WE SUGGEST TO
FOCUS ON. TRYING TO GET
ASSISTANCE AND RELIEF TO THE
PEOPLE BUSINESSES WHO HAVE BEEN
MOST IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC-
THE SECOND QUESTION WE SUGGEST
ASKING TO ENSURE THE STATE IS
GETTING THE BEST BANG FOR ITS
BUCK IS WHETHER OR NOT THE
STATE SPENDING ARE. A
COMPLEMENTING RATHER THAN
DUPLICATING FEDERAL EFFORTS-
LET ME GIVE YOU A RECENT
APPLICATION OF THIS PRINCIPLE
IN THE RECENTLY ADOPTED GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS- THE GOVERNOR
INITIALLY PROPOSED TARGETING
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS IN DIRECT
PAYMENTS TO. RECIPIENTS OF THE
STATE'S EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT. IN THE BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS ARE OFFICE
SUGGESTED- THAT THE STATE
PAYMENTS SHOULD BE TARGETED TO
A GROUP THAT TO DATE HAD BEEN
EXCLUDED. FROM THE VERY BROAD
FOR RELIEF EFFORTS AND IN
PARTICULAR THE- WE'RE- HE ABOUT
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS. ARE
INCONSISTENT WITH THIS- THE
ULTIMATE GOLDEN STATE SIMILIS A
PROGRAM THAT WAS PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE LAST MONTH INCLUDED
ENHANCED RELIEF. OTHER WAS
TARGETED TO UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS WHO HAD BEEN LEFT OUT
OF THE FEDERAL PROGRAMS.
ANOTHER SET OF QUESTIONS- THAT
WE WILL OFFER ATTEMPTS TO GAUGE
WHETHER THE BENEFITS OF A
PROPOSAL MAYBE ALTERNATELY BE
GREATER OR LESS THAN THEY MAY
INITIALLY APPEAR- FIRST IS
IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER HOW LARGE
THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ARE
BOTH. COST FOR STATE AGENCIES
AND COST TO- APPLICANTS OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. OF AN
ECONOMIC STIMULUS PROGRAM
IDEALLY SHOULD BE A SMALL SHARE
OF THE OVERALL COST- BUT A
SMALL PROGRAM WITH A
COMPLICATED ENROLLMENT PROCESS
MAY HAVE RELATIVELY HIGH
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS IN THE
SKIN. DIMINISH THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR DELIVERING
THE INTENDED BENEFITS SO
THERE'S ALWAYS AN IMPORTANT
TRADE OFF TO BE CONSIDERED
ABOUT- YOU KNOW THE LEVEL OF
DETAIL AND NUANCE THAT THE
PROGRAM CAN INCORPORATE VERSES
THE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN. THAT
WE'RE PLACING ON PARTICIPANTS
AND STATE AGENCIES- RELATEDLY
WE SUGGEST TAKING ACCOUNT OF
WHETHER PROPOSAL- WOULD BE A
NEW OR EXISTING PROGRAM A NEW
PROGRAMS WILL TAKE TIME AND
RESOURCES TO SET UP AND THIS
AGAIN CAN LESSEN THE OVERALL
ECONOMIC BENEFITS OVER PROGRAM
IN CONCERT IN CONTRAST. TO THE
EXPANDING EXISTING PROGRAM OR
INSTITUTION CAN BE LEVERAGED OF
THESE CONCERNS ARE LESS AND- WE
ALSO SUGGEST ASKING ENSURING-
ARE WE AVOIDING. UNNECESSARY
DUPLICATION OF EFFORT OUR
BEFORE CREATING A NEW PROGRAM
TO THE STATE SPEND STATE FUNDS
ARE TO RECEIVE FEDERAL FUNDS.
WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
POLICYMAKERS TO TAKE STOCK OF
THE EXISTING A RELATED EFFORTS
AT FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
LEVELS- HAVING MANY SIMILAR
PROGRAMS SPREAD ACROSS
DIFFERENT STATE AGENCIES ARE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT-
CAN BE INEFFICIENT IT CAN BE
CONFUSING FOR PEOPLE OR
BUSINESSES THE PROGRAMS ARE
INTENDED TO BENEFIT. ARE WE
ALSO SUGGEST ASKING WHETHER THE
PROGRAM WILL EFFECTIVELY
INCREASE PRIVATE SECTOR HIRING
INVESTMENT- WHERE THE WHERE THE
GOAL PROGRAM IS TO ENCOURAGE
CERTAIN PRIVATE SECTOR
ACTIVITIES- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CONSIDER- ENSURE THAT THE
INCENTIVE PROVIDED IS LARGE
ENOUGH. IMPROPERLY TARGETED TO
ACTUALLY CHANGE THE DECISIONS
OF PEOPLE OR BUSINESSES IN THE
WAY THAT IS INTENDED. OUR WE
ALSO SUGGEST ASKING A LOOKING
INTO WHETHER THEIR CONSTRAINTS.
IN THE RELEVANT LABOR MARKETS
AND CERTAIN CONDITIONS CAN MAKE
ECONOMIC STIMULUS MORE OR LESS
EFFECTIVE AND INCREASING
EMPLOYMENT FOR EXAMPLE- OUR
PROGRAM AIMED AT STIMULUS CAN
BE LESS EFFECTIVE WHEN THERE
ARE CONSTRAINTS THAT WOULD MAKE
HIRING FOR THE PROJECT OR
PROGRAM DIFFICULT FOR EXAMPLE.
IF UNEMPLOYMENT IS VERY LOW
AMONG KEY OCCUPATIONS NEEDED
FOR PROJECT. FINALLY I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT ARE HOW
MUCH FUNDING WILL BE SPENT
OUTSIDE THE STATE- BECAUSE OUR
ECONOMY IS CLOSELY INTEGRATED
WITH OTHER STATES AND OTHER
COUNTRIES I CAN BE IMPORTANT
DISCUSS WHAT A PORTION. OF THE
WORKERS AND MATERIALS WERE
PROJECT WILL COME FROM WITHIN
CALIFORNIA OF THOSE THAT USE-
MORE LOCALLY SOURCED SOURCED
WORKERS- OR MATERIALS I'M MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE A LARGER IMPACT
ON THE STATE'S ECONOMY. AT
LEAST IN THE NEAR TERM. WELL
THE FINAL TWO QUESTIONS IN OUR
FRAMEWORK THAT WE SUGGEST
CONSIDERING. AIM TO ENSURE THAT
PROGRAM IS PROVIDING BENEFITS
WHEN AND WHERE THE LEGISLATURE
WANTS THEM. FOR SIMPLY PUT WILL
THE BENEFITS TO BE REALIZED
QUICKLY. IT STANDS TO REASON I
THINK THAT NEW PUBLIC SPENDING
IS LIKELY TO BEMORE EFFECTIVE
AT STIMULATING THE ECONOMY I
DURING IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING
THE SESSION. THE RECESSION
STARTED LIKE THE PERIOD THAT
WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW. AND FOR
THIS REASON IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CAREFULLY ASSESS AND MAKE
PRACTICAL SANCTIONS ABOUT WHEN.
THE BENEFITS OF A PROGRAM OR
PROJECT CAN BE REALIZED AND WE
THINK RIGHT NOW GIVEN WHERE THE
STATE IS IN IT AND IT'S
RECOVERY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
FOCUS ON. BENEFITS THAT CAN BE-
THEY CAN BE- DISTRIBUTED INTO
THE ECONOMY QUICKLY- WE ALSO
SUGGEST ASKING HOW WOULD THE
BENEFITS BE DISTRIBUTED ACROSS
DIFFERENT- POPULATIONS AND
REGIONS OF THE STATE- SOME
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
PROGRAMS TARGET INVESTMENT IN
AREAS OF THE STATE WITH HIGH
POVERTY AND HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT.
I AM WHEN CONSIDERING A
PROPOSALS LIKE THESE WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO CAREFULLY
SCRUTINIZE THE RULES AND
STANDARDS USED TO IDENTIFY-
THESE AREAS OF SEVERAL PAST
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN INEFFECTIVE
ALONG THESE LINES BECAUSE
THEY'VE HAD OVERLY BROAD OR
AMBITIOUS TARGETING. ALSO IN
THE VEIN OF DISTRIBUTION- WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
THAT. OUR PROGRAMS ARE NOT
EXACERBATING EXISTING
INEQUITIES ACROSS COMMUNITIES
ACROSS REGIONS OF THE STATE AND
ONE IMPORTANT- WAY OF THINKING
ABOUT TIS IS WHETHER OR NOT
THERE WILL BE- DISADVANTAGES OF
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES IN
ACCESSING PROGRAM FUNDS OR
APPLYING FOR FUNDS. AND HOW
THOSE DISADVANTAGES CAN BE
TAKEN TO AN ACCOUNT IN THE IN
THE APPLICATION PROCESS IS-
HAVING OUTLINED ARE KIND OF OUR
SET OF QUESTIONS LET ME OFFER
SOME COMMENTS. ON SOME A RECENT
PROPOSALS IN LIGHT OF OUR
FRAMEWORK- FIRST OFFER SOME
COMMENTS ON A PACKAGE OF
BUSINESS TAX INCENTIVES. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED AS PART OF
HIS JANUARY BUDGET- THESE
PROPOSALS INCLUDE A ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR EXPANSION OF A
SALES TAX EXCLUSION FOR CERTAIN
EQUIPMENT PURCHASERS IS
MINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY AND ADVANCED
TRANSPORTATION FINANCING
AUTHORITY OR CAVE UP. AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THE SO CALLED- MAIN STREET
SMALL BUSINESS TAX CREDIT WHICH
IS A HIRING CREDIT FOR
BUSINESSES THAT FACE REVENUE
LOSSES DURING THE PANDEMIC.
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
MILLION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETES PROGRAM. TO PROVIDE
TWO TYPES OF ASSISTANCE AND A
TRACKING OR TRAINING BUSINESSES
TO CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A NEW. GRANT PROGRAM UNDER
CALIFORNIA COMPETES. AND A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ADDITIONAL TAX
CREDITS. FINALLY HE PROPOSES A
NEW OPTION FOR OWNERS OF S.
CORPORATIONS TO RESTRUCTURE
THEIR STATE INCOME TAXES. IN A
WAY THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
REDUCE THEIR FEDERAL INCOME TAX
LIABILITY- AND EVALUATING THIS
PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS WE FOUND-
THAT THE PROPOSAL'S TO EXPAND
KATE FOR A IN CALIFORNIA
COMPETES. I DO NOT OFFER
BENEFITS THAT ARE WELL TARGETED
TO THE BUSINESSES MOST
IMPACTED. BY THE PANDEMIC- WELL
SOME OF THESE PROPOSED FUNDS
COULD BENEFIT FIRMS- THAT HAVE
FACED CHALLENGES DURING THE
PANDEMIC THE DESIGN OF THESE
PROGRAMS DOES NOT EXPLICITLY
TARGET A BUSINESSES MOST
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC- NOR
DOES IT ENSURE THAT THOSE
BUSINESSES ULTIMATELY RECEIVE
FUNDING- MORE OVER SOME OF THE
IMPACTED SECTORS. OF SOME OF
THE MOST IMPACTED SECTORS LIKE
LEAVING THE HOSPITALITY AND
PERSONAL SERVICES. ARE
CATEGORICALLY INELIGIBLE FOR
THESE PROGRAMS. WE ALSO FIND
THAT THE BENEFITS FROM THESE
RIPPLES WOULD NOT BE
PARTICULARLY TIMELY- IN MOST
CASES THE BENEFITS ARE AWARDED
TO FIRMS OVER A NUMBER OF
MONTHS OR OFTEN YEARS-
RELATEDLY THE PROPOSAL TO AWARD
GRANTS UNDER CAL COMPETES FOR
THE FIRST TIME RAISES
SIGNIFICANT POLICY QUESTIONS
THAT WE THINK WARRANT. CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND MAKES THE
PROPOSAL ILL SUITED. FOR THE
ACCELERATED TIME'S UP THE
ACCELERATEDTIMELINE- THAT WE
THINK IS NECESSITATED BY THE
STATE'S CURRENT ECONOMIC
SITUATION. ON THE FLIP SIDE.
THE MAIN STREET A CREDIT WE
FEEL IS- PARTICULARLY WELL
TARGETED TO BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE BEEN MOST IMPACTED- AND
THIS IS ALMOST BY DEFINITION OF
WHAT BUSINESSES WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THE CREDIT-
WE THEREFORE HAVE SUGGESTED THE
LEGISLATURE FOCUS RESOURCES ON
EXPANDING THIS PROGRAM- AND
OPTIONS TO DO SO INCLUDED ARE
BROADENING THE ELIGIBILITY TO
INCLUDE- NEWLY ESTABLISHED
FIRMS- AND INCREASING. THE
AMOUNT OF THE TAX CREDIT-
PROVIDED FOR EACH NEW EMPLOYEE.
ANOTHER KEY APPROACH TO
SUPPORTING ECONOMIC RECOVERY
THAT HAS BEEN PROPOSED AT BOTH
THE FEDERAL AND STATE LEVEL. IS
INCREASED INFRASTRUCTURE
SPENDING- FUNCTIONING AND WELL
MAINTAINED PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE IS UNDOUBTEDLY
IMPORTANT TO THE STATE'S OUT
LONG TERM ECONOMIC PROSPECTS.
THAT BEING SAID I THINK WE
WOULD REITERATE SOME POINTS-
FROM A FRAMEWORK THAT I JUST
OUTLINED THAT WE THINK ARE
IMPORTANT WHEN THINKING ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE AS A TOOL TO
SUPPORT NEAR TERM. ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY. FIRST WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CAREFULLY
SCRUTINIZE- HOW MANY MORE
PROJECTS CAN PRACTICALLY GET
STARTED WHILE ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS REMAIN. DEPRESSED-
LANANE PERMITTING AND DESIGN OF
MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
OFTEN TAKES YEARS TO COMPLETE
AND GIVEN THE LONG TERM
IMPORTANCE OF MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS ARE
RUSHING THESE PLANNING PHASES
MAY NOT REALLY MAKE SENSE IN
MANY CASES- AND THIS WILL LIMIT
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THE STATE
CAN GET INTO THE ECONOMY. IN
THE NEAR TERM THROUGH NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS- THAT
BEING SAID. WAS THIS DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THE PROCESS SHOULD
NOT BE STARTED NOW- FOR
WORTHWHILE PROJECTS- THAT WILL
SUPPORT THE STATE'S LONG TERM
ECONOMIC GROWTH. THAT'S
ESPECIALLY TRUE IF WE DO SEE A
MAJOR FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING PACKAGE GO FORWARD TO
SUPPORT THESE KINDS OF PROJECTS
AT THE STATE LEVEL- ONE OPTION
THOUGH TO EXPAND INFRASTRUCTURE
DOLLARS MORE QUICKLY OUR COULD
BE TO FOCUS ON ACCELERATING
NECESSARY DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
OF STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FACILITIES- ANOTHER QUESTION
THAT WE WOULD POSE ABOUT-
INFRASTRUCTURE IS A NEAR TERM
ECONOMIC RECOVERY TOOL. IS
WHETHER THE STATE HAS A
STRATEGY IN PLACE TO RECEIVE
FEDERAL FUNDS IN A COORDINATED
MANNER AND AVOID DUPLICATION OF
EFFORT ACROSS AGENCIES- RIGHT
NOW WE'RE NOT SO. CONFIDENT
THAT SUBJECT A PLAN EXISTS- AND
LET ME KIND OF GIVE YOU ONE
EXAMPLE THAT IS DRAWN FROM A
POT OF MONEY AVAILABLE UNDER
THE AMERICAN A RESCUE PLAN-
SPECIFICALLY THE A. R. P.
INCLUDES. A TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR STATES TO DO INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THAT DIRECTLY ENABLE.
WORK EDUCATION AND HEALTH
MONITORING IN RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC- AND WE THINK THAT
THERE ARE SOME KIND OF JUST
BASIC UNIT UNANSWERED QUESTIONS
ABOUT THIS PART OF MONEY IN THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO DEPLOY IT-
SPECIFICALLY- WHICH IT'S NOT
CLEAR WHICH THE DEPARTMENT WILL
BE COORDINATING THE EFFORTS
ACROSS STATE AGENCIES TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE LEAVING ANY MONEY
ON THE TABLE AND THAT PROJECTS-
ARE. ARE FOLLOWING SOME SORT OF
STRATEGY. WHAT TYPES OF
PROJECTS CAN BE STARTED FASTER
THAN OTHERS. AND IT'S ALSO NOT
CLEAR HOW THE STATE PLANS TO-
PRIORITIZE. ANY FEDERAL FUNDING
THAT MAY BE AVAILABLE- UNDER
THIS PROVISION- FINALLY WE
SUGGESTS- CONSIDERING HOW THE
STATE'S EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE
PLAN. BOMB CAN ALIGN WITHIN
COMPLEMENT ATTENTION FEDERAL
EFFORTS- FOR EXAMPLE ARE WE
PRIORITIZING STATE PROJECTS. IN
AREAS THAT ARE UNLIKELY TO
RECEIVE FEDERAL FUNDING-
SIMILAR- ARE WE MAXIMIZING OUR
ELIGIBILITY AND USE OF FEDERAL
FUNDS IN GENERAL- SPENDING
FEDERAL FUNDING ON
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT OR- IN
THE PROGRAM IN THE STATE IS
LIKELY TO RESULT IN GREATER
ECONOMIC BENEFITS FOR THE STATE
ECONOMY OVERALL- BECAUSE AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE STATE SPENDING
COMES WITH THIS THIS DIRECT
TRADE OFF OF BEING AVAILABLE
FOR OTHER STATE PROGRAMS-
SIMILARLY WE SUGGEST
CONSIDERING. HOW THE STATE HOW
DOES THE STRATEGY ALSO CAN BESTCOMPLEMENT LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE
EFFORTS- SO WITH THAT- THAT
KIND OF CONCLUDES MY SUMMARY OF
OUR OUR FRAMEWORK AND ITS
APPLICATION AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MISTER
YOUR FOR JOINING US TODAY AND
THANK YOU FOR SHARING SOME KEY
QUESTIONS SUGGESTIONS THAT WE
SHOULD BE ASKRI ASKING AND
CONSIDERING. I WILL START OFF
WELL MAYBE WITH THE QUESTIONER
TO AND GIVES OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN
AND START. AS WE LOOK AT- JUST
DISPARITIES AND ACCESSIBLE WHAT
DO YOU RECOMMEND AS TO WHAT
ACTIONS THE LEGISLATURE THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN TAKE TO
REALLY MITIGATE THE
DISPARITIES. AMONG DIFFERENT
BUSINESS OWNER GROUPS I'D SAY
WOMEN BUSINESS OWNERS ARE
BUSINESSES LOCATED IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES HE- YEAH- SO I
THINK THAT THERE'S A FEW
OPTIONS- YOU KNOW HIGHLIGHTING
A FEW POINTS FROM FROM THE
FRAMEWORK OUTLINED I THINK ONE
THING- THAT THAT CAN BE AN
IMPORTANT TOOL IS. HAVING
TARGETING OF PROGRAMS OR
PRIORITIZATION OF- TECHNOMIC
DEVELOPER PROGRAMS BASED ON.
WHETHER OR NOT BUSINESSES ARE
LOCATED AND HISTORICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- YOU
KNOW AND I THINK A LOT OF
PROGRAMS AS I MENTIONED I'VE
HAD THOSE KINDS OF- PARAMETERS
IN THE PAST- IT'S IMPORTANT-
THAT YOU KNOW THE WERE SURE
THAT THE MORE PUTTING THIS
PRIMARIES IN PLACE THOUGH-
SINCE YOU KNOW DEFINING THOSE
THINGS I NARROWLY ENOUGH TO
ACTUALLY IDENTIFY. A PROPERLY
IDENTIFY GROUPS THAT ARE MOST
IN NEED OF ASSISTANCE- OFTEN
THERE CAN BE A TEMPTATION TO
DEFINE THOSE- THOSE PARAMETERS
VERY A PROBABLY- SO THE FUNDS
ARE DISTRIBUTED TO MANY PARTS
OF THE STATE- INSTEAD OF KIND
OF TARGETED AT THAT THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ANOTHER- THREE FOUR ONE IS-
ENSURING. THAT ANY ANY PROGRAM
THAT DOES HAVE- INVOLVED
APPLICATION PROCESS. THERE IS
FUNDING SET ASIDE FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR US SMALLER
COMMUNITIES ARE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND ALSO- OFTEN I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
FUNDING FOR- OUR RECENT OUT
REACH AND AN EDUCATION FOR
BUSINESS OWNERS TO- YOU KNOW WE
MAY YOU KNOW MAY MAY NOT HAVE.
THE TIME OR RESOURCES TO BE
STAYING APPRISED OF ALL YOU
KNOW THE KIND OF STATE PROGRAMS
THAT MAY BE AVAILABLE TO THEM.
THANK YOU MISTER YOU ARE I WILL
TURN IT OVER TO. MY RIGHT TO
SOMEONE NUMBER BOERNER HORVATH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION- WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE TARGETED STIMULUS TO THOSE
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU SAID IN YOUR
REPORT WHO MAY BE LESS PREPARED
TO COMPETE FOR THIS TARGET IS
TENUOUS. AT THIS POINT WHAT ARE
THE TOP FIVE REASONS OF REGIONS
SORRY ONE OF THE FIVE TOP FIVE
REGIONS AND INDUSTRIAL
CLASSIFICATIONS YOU THINK CAN
MOST BENEFIT FROM TARGET
STIMULUS IN CALIFORNIA SO IF WE
WERE TO BREAK IT DOWN FOR US.
WHAT ARE YOUR TOP FIVE. TOP
FIVE- I THINK ON THE REGIONAL
PEACE I HONESTLY WOULD- I THINK
I WOULD HAVE TO I THINK YOU
HAVE TO GET BACK ON THE
REGIONAL PEACE ON THE SECTORS-
I THINK I GUESS IT DEPENDS A
LITTLE BIT ON WHAT LEVEL OF
INDUSTRIAL CODE- BUT I THINK-
FAR AWAY THE THIS THE SECTORS
THAT HAVE BEEN. SEEN THE
GREATEST IMPACT FROM THE
PANDEMIC AND CONTINUE TO SEE
THE GREATEST DECLINES IN
EMPLOYMENT AND DECLINES IN
BUSINESS OUR RECEIPTS. ARE IN
LEISURE AND HOSPITALITY- ARTS
AND RECREATION AND PERSONAL
SERVICES. THAT GROUP BEING-
THEY'RE THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY LOTS
OF BUSINESSES IN THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC BUT I
THINK THAT BUSINESSES IN THOSE
SECTORS- THEY CONTINUE TO SEE
KIND OF DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACTS ROLE RELATIVE TO OTHER
GROUPS AND I MEAN I WOULD BE.
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH- WITH
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AFTERWARDS
TO- TO PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT
MORE DETAIL ON THE ON THE
REGIONAL QUESTION SORRY I DON'T
I DON'T HAVE KIND OF AT HAND.
SOME SOME DETAILED INFORMATION
ON THE REGIONAL PEACE. YEAH SO
THAT WOULD BE GREAT IF YOU
COULD FOLLOW UP AND
SPECIFICALLY WHAT WOULD BE
INTERESTING IS THE OVERLAP OF
THE SECTORS IN THE REGION'S FOR
TARGETED STIMULUS SO THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL. THANK YOU MISTER
YOU ARE. LET ME GO AHEAD AND
JUST QUICKLY ASK REQUIRE AS A
RELATES TO ALL OF THE FEDERAL
AND STATE LOAN PROGRAMS THAT
ARE OUT THERE. HAVE YOU HAD A
CHANCE TO IDENTIFY ANY GAPS IN
FINANCING BEING OFFERED WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
ELIGIBILITY AND CRITERIA AND
REQUIREMENTS ARE THERE CERTAIN
LOANS. I SIZE THOSE THAT ARE
BEING LEFT OUT. ALONG. YOU KNOW
I THINK THAT THAT'S A THAT'S A
VERY GOOD QUESTION I THINK
THAT- THE LOAN GUARANTEE
PROGRAMS- IS AN AREA THAT OUR
OFFICE- IS KIND OF I THINK
HOPING TO. TO DRILL DOWN INTO A
LITTLE MORE IN THE COMING
MONTHS- IN LIGHT OF- KIND OF A
COLLECTION OF PROPOSALS THE
GOVERNOR'S FORWARD- FOR SOME.
LOAN GUARANTEE PROGRAMS
THROUGH- THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF BUSINESS. OUR GOAL IS SORRY-
AND- SO YOU KNOW THERE ARE A
LOT OF PROGRAMS THERE WITH LOTS
OF DIFFERENT MOVING PIECES. YOU
KNOW I THINK I DON'T HAVE A
GOOD ANSWER FOR YOU RIGHT NOW
AND IF THERE ARE CLEAR- GROUPS
THAT ARE BEING LEFT OUT- I KNOW
THAT LIKE A KEY. OBJECTIVE OF
SOME OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS HAS BEEN TO TARGET-
GROUPS WHO ARE NOT AVAILABLE OR
ARE NOT ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
SOME OF THE LARGER FEDERAL
PROGRAMS- LIKE- PPP OR IDLE-
ARE RIGHT NOW- I THINK IT'S A
LITTLE BIT EARLY TO SEE WHETHER
OR NOT SOME OF THOSE EFFORTS
BY. THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE ACHIEVED
THEIR GOAL OF ACTUALLY
TARGETING THOSE POPULATIONS.
THAT HAVE BEEN ABLE ELIGIBLE
FOR THOSE PROGRAMS- BUT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HOPE THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO MONITOR PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
YOU KNOW DURING BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS ON THOSE
PROPOSALS. UNDERSTAND I BELIEVE
MATH PETRIE-NORRIS. THANK YOU
CARE. HI AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US TODAY AND- FOR
YOUR ANALYSIS PARTICULARLY ON
ASTHMA THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS.
I THINK I WAS PARTICULARLY
STRUCK BY YOUR COMMENTS I
REGARDING JUST THE LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE OR COORDINATION
AVAILABLE AT THE STATE LEVEL
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS- YOU
HIGHLIGHTED A NUMBER OF GAP
SOME POTENTIAL ISSUES AND- AND
HURDLES. DO YOU HAVE ANY
PROPOSALS OR SOLUTIONS IN TERMS
OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO IN ORDER
TO BETTER COORDINATE. THAT TYPE
OF THAT THAT TYPE OF SPENDING.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK- THAT. YOU
KNOW THE STATE HAS A
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN THAT WAS
RELEASED AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUT- OF RELEASE
ALONG WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THIS YEAR- AND YOU KNOW
I THINK THAT THERE IS THERE ARE
SOME OPPORTUNITIES- TO
POTENTIALLY- AND ABOUT WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION BRING
THE ADMINISTRATION AND ASK THEM
TO- EVALUATE THAT STRATEGY
ONLINE AS SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT WE RAISED I THINK- YOU
KNOW ASKING THEM TO AYE. YOU
KNOW IDENTIFY IN PARTICULAR HOW
THE PROJECTS AND THE STRATEGIES
THAT HAVE BEEN OUTLINED PLAN-
YOU KNOW BASICALLY ASKING THEM
TO SUPPLEMENT THAT PLAN WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT. HOW THE PLAN
COULD OVERLAP- WITH- FEDERAL
BILLS THAT ARE COMING IN AND
WHAT STRATEGIES THE
ADMINISTRATION SUGGEST PUTTING
IN PLACE FOR- ENSURING THAT
WE'RE DRAWING DOWN THE MAXIMUM
AMOUNT OF FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
THOSE PROJECTS- SO YOU KNOW I
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
HAS. STARTED SOME OF THE WORK
ALONG HIS LINES- BUT IT'S NOT
CLEAR TO US THAT. YOU KNOW AT
THE MOMENT THAT A LOT OF
THOUGHT HAS BEEN GIVEN TO- HOW
HOW THE STATE'S PLAN. WOOD
INTERACT WITH- YOU KNOW CONTENT
PROPOSED FEDERAL ACTIONS AND
HOW WE'RE ENSURING THAT WE'RE
MAXIMIZING THOSE DOLLARS. AND
IF I UNDERSTOOD YOU CORRECTLY
ARE BIG AND IMPORTANTLY MISSING
PIECE IS GOOD CLEAR OWNERSHIP.
AND RESPONSIBILITY FOR DECISION
MAKING AND EXECUTION ACROSS
WITH IT INSTEAD OF HAVING
DIFFUSE RESPONSIBILITY
SCATTERED ACROSS A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT AGENCIES. YEAH YEAH
THAT'S RIGHT I HAD AN KIND OF
ON IT THE SIMILAR VEIN I. THINK
ONE THING THAT I'VE BEEN REALLY
STRUCK BY BAD THROUGHOUT THE
COURSE OF OUR PANDEMIC RESPONSE
HAS BEEN ANOTHER THING THAT
SEEMS IMPORTANTLY MISSING WHICH
IS KIND OF A REAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. AGENCY FOR THE
STATE SO IF I UNDER THE DAVIS
ADMINISTRATION WHAT WAS IT
CALLED THE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TECHNOLOGY TRADE AND COMMERCE
AGENCY WAS ELIMINATED AND WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE AS A RESULT
A- FIVE. AND THAT THE FULL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT THAT THAT YOU IN
LA- HAVE DISCUSSED ARE THERE
OPPORTUNITIES THERE ARE OTHER
THINGS THAT THAT WE'RE- MISSING
AS A RESULT OF THAT. WELL YOU
KNOW I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION I THINK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION MIGHT SUGGEST.
THAT THEY GO BUSINESS CURRENTLY
SERVING THAT ROLE AND I THINK
MAYBE IN A LOT OF RESPECTS-
THEY ARE I THINK THAT'S YOU
KNOW- SO YEAH I MEAN I THINK
THAT THAT THEY GO IS YOU KNOW-
FILLING THAT ROLE TO A LARGE
EXTENT- FOR THE STATE- YOU KNOW
I THINK MAYBE ONE THING- ONE
YOU KNOW POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITY
SO TO LOOK AT GOING FORWARD-
WITH GO BIZ OR OR- YOU KNOW
POTENTIALLY WITH SOME OTHER
STATE AGENCY- IS THE- THE
EXTENT TO WHICH- THE STATE IS.
IS WORKING WITH LOCALS- TO-
WORKING WITH LOCALS TO- WORKING
ALONGSIDE LOCAL SORRY WITH
THEIR LOCAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS- TO AGAIN
ENSURE YOU KNOW HOW WHAT WHAT
THINGS CAN THE STATE DO SUPPORT
THOSE PROGRAMS HOW CAN WE GET
HOW CAN WE ENSURE THAT THERE
ISN'T- DUPLICATION OF EFFORT
ACROSS THE STATE AND LOCAL
PROGRAMS AND MAYBE EVEN TO SOME
EXTENT IN THE STATE PLAY A
ROLE- AND MAYBE EVEN SOME
REGIONAL COORDINATION OF THOSE
THOSE LOCAL EFFORTS TO MAYBE
ENSURE THAT THERE IS AN-
UNHEALTHY COMPETITION HAPPENING
AMONGST LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
GOT IT AB ONE LAST QUESTION AND
AS WE TALKED ABOUT THAT WHAT IS
IT TWO WEEKS AGO AND THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED A SEVEN POINT
SIX BILLION DOLLAR ECONOMIC
STIMULUS PACKAGE YOU TALKED
ABOUT SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
ELEMENTS THAT WERE INCLUDED AS
PART OF THAT WERE THERE ANY
SPECIFIC POLICY PROPOSALS THAT
THAT ENDED UP ON THE CUTTING
ROOM FLOOR THAT YOU OR THE L.
A. O. WOULD. LIKE TO ENCOURAGE
US TO CONSIDER FOR A SUBSEQUENT
POTENTIAL INVESTMENT ACTIONS. I
THINK THAT RIGHT NOW- THE THING
THAT OUR OFFICE IS HIGHLIGHTED
AS- KIND OF THE MOST IMPORTANT-
ACTIONS FOR THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION TO BE FOCUSING
ON IN TERMS OF ECONOMIC
RECOVERY I THINK THEY STILL
REMAIN- IN THE VEIN OF
SUPPORTING THE KIND OF JUST THE
OVERALL PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE-
WE THINK. KIND OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THE STATE CAN
DO FOR BUSINESSES RIGHT NOW- IS
TO CONTINUE CONTINUE TO ENSURE
AN ORDERLY- ROLLOUT OF THE
VACCINES CONTINUE TESTING- TO.
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH. INDUSTRY
GROUPS TO ENSURE THAT THAT
REGULATIONS ADAPT TO THE
CHANGING SITUATIONS THAT ARE
ALLOWING BUSINESSES. TO COME
BACK INTO THEIR OPERATIONS- SO-
FOCUSING ON- WHERE. ADDITIONAL
SPENDING MAY BE NEEDED FOR
VACCINE- DEPLOYMENT FOR- FOR
SUPPORTING BUSINESSES TO.
REOPEN OPERATIONS- I THINK
THOSE ARE KIND OF THE KEY THE
KEY AREAS FOR SUPPORTING
ECONOMIC RECOVERY GOING
FORWARD. I THANK COULDN'T AGREE
MORE THANK YOU SO MUCH I MISTER
YOU ARE WITH JUST A I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME BEING WITH
US THIS MORNING AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SOME OF THE FOLLOW
UP- THAT WILL BE HAVING. IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME LET ME GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
AGENDA ITEM- LET ME. JUST GIVE
A BRIEF FRAMEWORK FOR AGENDA
ITEM FOR AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE STATE'S
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FEDERAL
WORKFORCE INNOVATION
OPPORTUNITY ACT. THE BOARD ALSO
PROVIDES ADVICE TO THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE AND JOURNAL
THERE'S GENERALLY SERVES AS THE
STATE'S PRIMARY PLACE AWARE
LABOR BUSINESS AND INDUSTRY AS
WELL AS EDUCATION STAKEHOLDERS
COME TOGETHER. COVER NINETY
DISPLACING EXTREME CHALLENGES
ON OUR WORK FORCE COMMUNITY
JUST BASED ON NUMBERS RELEASED
ON FRIDAY THERE ARE ONE POINT
SIX MILLION UNEMPLOYED PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA WITH OVER THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND AND NATIONAL YOU
AYE OR PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTING CLAIMS. ARE BEING
FILED LAST WEEK. SO THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE AREAS WERE GOING BACK
TO PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS I CAN
NOT BE OUR GOALS. MORE THAN
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
WORKFORCE HAPPY LASSEN A
BACHELORS DEGREE. AND MORE
STAGNATION IN WAGES HAVE PLACED
NEARLY 18% OF THE HOUSEHOLDS IN
CALIFORNIA. LIVING ON POVERTY
LEVEL INCOMES WE MUST BUILD
BACK BETTER. ONE THING IN OUR
FAVOR IS THAT THE GOVERNOR WAS
AND IS KEENLY AWARE OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S WORKPLACE
CHALLENGES. MOST RECENTLY HIS
FUTURE WORK COMMISSION
RELEASED. A REPORT WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS TO SUPPORT LONG
TERM ECONOMIC COMPETITIVENESS
AND BY THE SUMMER- THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD WILL HAVE A
WORKFORCE STRATEGY. TO PROVIDE
A JUST TRANSITION TO A LOWER
CARBON ECONOMY. SO WITH THAT
LET'S GO HEADING HERE FROM
TIMBER RAINY OUR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD. I
TIM WHEN YOU ARE READY TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR I
HOPE YOU CAN HEAR ME OKAY. YES
WE CAN. THE TRAFFIC- OPENING I
COULDN'T SAID IT BETTER MYSELF-
AND I'LL TRY NOT TO REPEAT WHAT
YOU SAID BUT BUT BUILT ON IT-
AND I'LL BE BRIEF- BECAUSE I
WANNA LEAVE TIME FOR QUESTIONS
M. AND ALSO BECAUSE ARE MUCH
SMARTER PEOPLE ON THE PANEL.
THAT COMES AFTER ME AND MY
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES RON
MILLER LANCE HASTINGS. SO I'LL
QUICKLY COVER WHERE I THINK WE
ARE- WHERE WE NEED TO BE AND
IDEAS ON HOW TO GET TO WHERE WE
NEED TO BE. AND WORKING FROM
SECRETARY SHOES- AND THE
GOVERNOR'S VISION FOR HIRING
RECOVERY SECRETARY SEE WHO I
SEND MY- ALL MY ENERGY TO
BECAUSE SHE'S. ON CAPITOL HILL
RIGHT NOW. IN THE MIDDLE OF
SENATE CONFIRMATION HEARING SO
I WISH HER THE ABSOLUTE BEST.
I'M AND IT MAYBE TOOK OFF A FEW
OPPORTUNITIES IF I CAN'T SO
WHERE WE ARE. IN NOT TO REPEAT.
EVERYTHING THAT MR MUELLER WELL
LAID OUT IN HIS PRESENTATION
ECONOMIC SHOCK. OF THE PANDEMIC
HIT. AS WE ALL KNOW THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS THE
HARDEST IMMIGRANTS PEOPLE OF
COLOR. LOW INCOME WORKERS
WOMEN. IN THE PANDEMIC DIDN'T
CREATE THESE UNJUST. CONDITIONS
AS YOU POINTED OUT MADAM CHAIR-
BUT IT EXACERBATED THOSE IT
LAID BARE THESE. DEEP
INEQUITIES IN OUR ECONOMY. SO I
THINK THE STRUCTURAL PROBLEM
BECAUSE THAT WAS A QUESTION
THAT WAS RAISED. OR A
STRUCTURAL PROBLEM AN IMPORTANT
ONE THAT WE WANT TO FOCUS ON
THAT WE ARE FOCUSED ON IS THAT
THE NUMBER OF GOOD QUALITY JOBS
IN CALIFORNIA. THAT NUMBER IS
FAR LESS THAN THAN THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO NEED GOOD. JOBS
THE TRADITIONAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT APPROACH. I THINK
IS INADEQUATE. WE TEND TO.
APPROACH WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
IN A WAY THAT LOOKS KIND KIND
OF FROM A PROGRAM CENTRIC
PERSPECTIVE- WE TRAIN WE
PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT SERVICES-
AND THEN WE SEND PEOPLE OUT IN
LABOR MARKETS KIND OF ON THEIR
OWN IN HOPES THAT THEY CONNECT
TO IT. A GOOD QUALITY JOB. WE
HOPE THAT WE'VE GIVEN HIM THE
WHERE WITH ALL TO BE
COMPETITIVE ENOUGH TO LAND A
GOOD JOB. PRESIDENT OBAMA WHEN
HE SIGNED THAT WORKFORCE
INNOVATION OPPORTUNITY ACT.
CALL THAT RAINING PRICE WHICH
I USE A LOT I THINK IT SUMS IT
UP. IN THE MICRO SENSE. THAT
WORKS OUT AND WE THINK ABOUT IT
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SITE
IS THAT YOU GIVE AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO WALKS IN THE DOOR A LEG UP
IN A COMPETITIVE LABOR MARKET
UP FOR GOOD QUALITY JOB THAT'S
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO. AND THAT
DOES WORK IN IN IN THAT
INDIVIDUAL'S CASE IN THE MACRO
IT DOESN'T WORK- BECAUSE WE'RE
BUILDING COMPETITION FOR TOO
FEW JOBS THAT'S A STRUCTURAL
PROBLEM AND IN THE END WHEN
WE'RE SUCCESSFUL AT BUILDING
COMPETITION FOR TOO FEW JOBS-
WE HAVE A DOWNWARD EFFECT ON ON
WAGES SO YOU REALLY HAVE TO
LINK UP WORKFORCE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN VERY INTENTIONAL
WAY- AND OF COURSE AS YOU AS
YOU WELL KNOW. THERE ARE VERY
REAL HISTORICAL IMPACTS OF
PRIVILEGE RACE AND GENDER ARE
UNTRUE AND WHAT GROUPS WIN OUT
IN THE CONTEXT OF COMPETITION
FOR TOO FEW A GOOD QUALITY JOBS
SO WHERE DO WE NEED TO BE. THE
AS- IF YOU ARE I THINK POINTED
FOR THE RECOVERY IS NOT TO
RETURN TO THE SAME ECONOMIC
INJUSTICES AND INEQUITIES OF
THE PAST BUT TO COME OUT
STRONGER MORE EQUITABLE AND
MORE RESILIENT- WE KNOW THAT.
EQUITY WE KNOW THAT SHARED
PROSPERITY A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
AS THE GOVERNOR SAYS. IS GOOD
FOR THE ECONOMY BROADLY WHEN
PEOPLE EARN MORE WHEN THEY HAVE
GREATER INCOME SECURITY WHEN
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO ONGOING
SKILLS TRAINING AND EDUCATION
AND THE ABILITY TO BE MOBILE
AND ROCK. ARE GREATER INCOME
SECURITY AS A RESULT OF THAT.
THAT'S GOOD FOR COMMUNITIES
IT'S VERY GOOD FOR FAMILY
STRENGTHENS FAMILIES- AND IT'S
GREAT FOR BUSINESS- HOW DO WE
GET THERE ARE. YOU THERE THERE
ARE THREE KIND OF MAIN
CATEGORIES THAT THAT WE THINK
ABOUT WHAT WE'VE GOT TO REALLY
BE INTENTIONAL ONE IS TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO GOOD QUALITY
JOBS. THROUGH EDUCATION
TRAINING BUT ALSO PARTNERSHIPS
WITH INDUSTRY. CREATE MORE GOOD
JOBS- THROUGH INVESTMENTS
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS IN
OTHER WAYS CREEK JUST INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF JOBS RELATIVE
GOOD JOBS RELATIVE TO THE
NUMBER OF BAD JOBS. AND THE
NUMBER THREE IS TO IMPROVE
EXISTING JOBS. AND I THINK THE
TECHNICAL TERM IS TO TURN
CRAPPIE JOBS AND GOOD JOBS BUT
I WON'T USE THAT TECHNICAL
TERM. THE HYBRID APPROACH IS
WHAT WE APPLY TO THIS AND IT'S-
I USE IN THE IN THE CONTEXT OF
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
THAT'S OFTEN. HOW WE TALK ABOUT
IT BUT IT'S ALSO APPLICABLES
MORE BROADLY I THINK THE
CONTRACTING AND PROCUREMENT.
AND HOW WE THINK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT. THE
HYBRID APPROACH. THAT IS A
SPECIFIC AN EMERGING FIELD OF
PRACTICE IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND HAS. FOUR MAIN
PILLARS THAT ARE QUICKLY TALK
ABOUT. THE FIRST JOB QUALITY
SECOND IS- IS WORKER VOICE
THIRTIES EQUITY IN THE LAST SIX
CLIMATE ON JOB QUALITY. THIS IS
TURNING THE TRADITIONAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT APPROACH
KIND OF ON ITS HEAD UPSIDE DOWN
SO YOU DON'T START WITH
PROGRAMS YOU KNOW PUSH PEOPLE
OUT LABOR MARKETS INSTEAD YOU
START WITH THE BEST QUALITY
JOBS. IN INDUSTRY SECTORS THAT
ARE DRIVING REGIONAL
EMPLOYMENT. IN THE DNA OF THIS
HYBRID APPROACH IS DEEP
INDUSTRY ENGAGEMENT. THAT
CREATES THE CONDITIONS BOTH FOR
WORKERS TRANSMIT ON THE JOB
MOVING PEOPLE UP. AND ALSO
ACCESS TO QUALITY JOBS FOR NEW
HIRES. ESPECIALLY COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE NOT HAD ACCESS TO
GOOD QUALITY JOBS TRADITIONALLY.
THE SECOND IS WORKER VOICE IN
AGENCY ON THE JOB ESPECIALLY AS
JOBS IN INDUSTRIES CHANGE. DUE
TO CLIMATE AUTOMATION AND
COVIDIEN PACKS OF COKE WORKERS
IN COMMUNITIES WERE MOST
IMPACTED NEED A SEAT AT THE
TABLE ARE IN CO DOT CO
DESIGNING. THE FUTURE WORK AND
THEN FINALLY NOT FINALLY EQUITY
TRADITIONAL WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
AS I AS I SAID FOCUS ON
POPULATIONS. WELL I DIDN'T SAY
THIS BUT IT'S IMPORTANT POINT
OUT TRADITIONAL WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS FOCUS ON POPULATIONS
WITH BEARS TO EMPLOYMENT SO
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS.
SOCIAL SERVICES PROGRAMS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO ME BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WERE VERY MISSION
DRIVEN UP ALREADY ARE ARE
TARGETING THOSE WORKERS WHO
HAVE. WHO NEED A GOOD JOB THE
MOST BUT ALSO NEED THE MOST
HELP TO GET THERE. ARE HOWEVER.
TO ACHIEVE EQUITY. YOU CAN'T
JUST WORK ON THE SUPPLY SIDE ON
WHAT WORKERS NEED YOU HAVE TO
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION TO JOB
QUALITY BECAUSE OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. PEOPLE WHO ARE
ARE UNDER EMPLOYED UNEMPLOYED
OR WORKING HARD TO STATE JUST
ABOVE POVERTY OFTEN WORKING
MORE THAN ONE JOB. DON'T NEED
ACCESS TO. ANOTHER LOW WAGE JOB
THAT'S DEAD AND WHAT THEY NEED
ACCESS TO YOU IS A GOOD QUALITY
JOBS SO THAT'S GOT TO BE OUR
FOCUS IF YOU. IF YOU WANT TO
ACHIEVE EQUITY ABSOLUTELY HAVE
TO PAY ATTENTION TO JOB
QUALITY- AND WE DON'T WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS IN A WAY THAT PULL
PEOPLE INTO GOOD QUALITY JOBS
INSTEAD OF PUSHING PEOPLE INTO
LABOR MARKETS TO FEND FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEN FINALLY A
CLIMATE SO FOCUS ON INDUSTRIES.
OCCUPATIONS WORKERS. AND
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MOST
IMPACTED BY CLIMATE- BUT ALSO
WORKERS INDUSTRIES AND
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE DISRUPTED
BY THIS PANDEMIC. AND ALSO
CHANGES IN OUR TECHNOLOGY AND
AUTOMATION SO NOT VERY QUICKLY
I'LL WRAP UP WITH JUST A FEW
OPPORTUNITIES. WERE REALLY
PUSHING. HARD TO BUILD MORE
SECTOR BASED HYBRID TRAIN
PARTNERSHIPS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL ASK FOR TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO THE STATE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO
BUILD MORE HIRING ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS OUT THERE- WE HAVE
TWENTY TWO WOULD CALL EACH OR
TNCS HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS. IN SECTORS THAT
ARE AS DIVERSE AS HOSPITALITY
TRADE AND LOGISTICS. AND
CONSTRUCTION- WE ALSO HAVE
ELEVEN FIRA CONSTRUCTION CREWS
PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE IN EVERY
CORNER OF THE STATE AND HAVE
THE ABILITY TO CONNECT
COMMUNITIES AND WORKERS WHO
HAVEN'T HAD ACCESS TO GOOD
QUALITY JOBS. GIVE THEM ACCESS
TO STATE APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS IN THE
TRADES AS WE BUILD OUR BECAUSE
OUR INVESTING IS DIMINISHED WE
HAVE NOW A MECHANISM TO GET
PEOPLE ACCESS TO. SOME OF THE
BEST MIDDLE CLASS JOBS THAT
DON'T REQUIRE A COLLEGE DEGREE.
AND THOSE ARE PARTNERSHIPS IN
EVERY REGION BETWEEN BUILDING
TRADES COUNCILS THE TRADES-
WORKFORCE BOARDS COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSAL CONDITIONS I THINK.
ABOUT MR MILLER WILL TALK MORE
ABOUT THAT. THE SECOND IS
PROCUREMENT CONTRACTING IS A
SAID APPLYING THOSE PRINCIPLES
OF HIGH ROAD- AND THEN FINALLY
THE FEDERAL. INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. RE REALIZING THE
STIMULUS IMPACTS OF THE
RECOVERY MONEY. MEANS CREATING
PATHWAYS TO GOOD JOBS THAT ARE
CREATED FOR THE PEOPLE. WHO
MOST NEED THOSE GOOD JOBS AND
I'LL I THINK I'LL LEAVE IT
THERE IN THE INTEREST OF TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH RESTRAINING
YOU TOUCHED ON SO MANY KEY
ISSUES THAT WE DISCUSSED ARE
VERY VERY OFTEN- WITHIN THIS
BODY AND ALSO WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES. I DO HAVE A QUICK
QUESTION AS IT RELATES TO OUR
TRANSITION TO A LOWER CARBON
ECONOMY HOW DO YOU SEE. THE
STATE'S TRANSITION TO LOWER
CARBON ECONOMY- IMPACTING
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. AND OUR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT NEEDS.
YEAH IT'S A IT'S DIRECTLY
RELATED SO WHAT WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING AND WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
TO DO IS LOOKING AT THOSE
SECTORS KNOWS COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE MOST IMPACTED BY OUR MOVE
TO WE HAVE A VERY AGGRESSIVE IN
GENTING CALIFORNIA TO MOVE TO-
NET ZERO- A CARBON TAX SO THAT
MEANS MANUFACTURING
CONSTRUCTION TRADE LOGISTICS
REALLY EVERY SECTOR IN THE
ECONOMY. IS GOING TO BE NEEDING
TO TRANSITION- AND THAT MEANS
ALSO BUILDING A WORKFORCE THAT
CAN MAKE THAT TRANSITION TO-
AND I WILL POINT OUT THAT MUCH
OF THAT FOCUS IS GOING TO BE ON
MANUFACTURING THAT SECTOR-
WHICH IS ALREADY IN IN IN A
PROCESS OF CHANGE I LOOKS VERY
YEARS AGO I THINK MISTER
HASTINGS WILL TALK ABOUT THAT.
IT ALSO CONSTRUCTION MOST OF
THE JOBS BETTER HE IN CENTRAL
TO- MITIGATING CLIMATE CHANGE
ARE ACTUALLY IN THE TRADITIONAL
TRADES SO OUR INTENTION AROUND
CREATING ACCESS TO THOSE JOBS
IN THE TRADES IS VERY DIRECTLY
RELATED TO OUR OUR SHIFT TO
CLIMATE RESILIENCY- AND I THINK
YOU JUST REAL QUICKLY IN
ADDITION TO THAT AS WE LOOK AT
HOW DO INVESTORS INFRASTRUCTURE
DOLLARS COMING IN FROM THE FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
WILL CREATE NEW JOBS. IN THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES AND I THINK
IT'S A HUGE OPPORTUNITY FOR US.
AS A STATE TO IMPACT EMPLOYMENT
KIND OF LIKE WE USED TO DO-
WITH GOVERNMENT STIMULUS
INVESTMENTS REALLY BEING
INTENTIONAL ABOUT IMPACTING ONE.
I'M LOOKING AT EARLIER THIS
MONTH WE KNOW THAT THE FUTURE
WORK COMMISSION RELEASED ITS
REPORT AND- ARE THERE
PARTICULAR RECOMMENDATIONS AT
THIS COMMITTEE SHOULD BE
REVIEWING AS THEY WERE AS IT
RELATES TO INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY- YEAH I IT'S A GREAT
REPORT AND I REALLY ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO GO TO THE LABOR
AGENCIES WEBSITE THERE'S A LINK
TO THE TO THE REPORT- ON ON THE
WEBSITE. L. W. D. EIGHT NO I'M
SORRY IT'S LABOR DOT CA DOT
GOP- I THINK THE BASIC PREMISE
OF THE FUTURE WORK COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATIONS IS NOT WHAT I
SAID BEFORE. THAT YOU CAN'T
ACHIEVE EQUITY WHICH IS A FOCUS
OF THE STATE IN GETTING TO. AN
INCLUSIVE HIGH ROAD RECOERY
YOU CAN'T ACHIEVE THAT AN
EQUITY WE DON'T PAY ATTENTION
TO JOB QUALITY SO THEIR NUMBER
OF RECOMMENDATIONS IN THERE
INCLUDING INVESTING AND HIRING
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS THAT GIVE
THAT QUESTION OF JOB. JOB
QUALITY. I WANT TO MAKE SURE
TURN IT TO ANY OF MY- OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME HE- IT
IF PETRIE-NORRIS. HI AB TWENTY
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
TODAY. SO I FEEL LIKE THERE IS
A HUGE AND I'M SURE WHO CREATE
UNREALIZED OPPORTUNITY FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT ACROSS
THE STATE SO AND THE FOR THE
PANDEMIC I THINK YOU YOU
POINTED OUT THAT THERE'S TOO
MANY CALIFORNIANS COMPETING FOR
TOO FEW GOOD JOBS. BUT WE ARE
ALSO SEEING JOB GROWTH SLOWING
NOT BECAUSE THERE WEREN'T
ENOUGH GOOD JOBS WITH BECAUSE
THE SKILLS OF OUR LABOR MARKET.
AREN'T AT WHERE THEY NEED TO BE
FOR TODAY'S INCREASINGLY
TECHNOLOGY DRIVEN ECONOMY SO I
THINK THERE'S A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US. TO INVEST
IN WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
ENSURE THAT WE ARE FORGING THIS
INCLUSIVE RECOVERY AND ENSURING
THAT WE ARE BUILDING BACK
BETTER WHICH IS CERTAINLY. A
GOAL THAT WE ALL SHARE. I GUESS
I WOULD LOVE TO UNDERSTAND FROM
YOUR AND YOUR PERSPECTIVE WHAT
ARE THE CONSTRAINTS RIGHT NOW
HI IN TERMS OF OUR ABILITY TO
INVEST MORE IN. IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND GET MORE. GET
MORE FROM FROM THE PROGRAMS
THAT YOU'RE RENTING IS IT
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH FUNDING IS
IT THAT THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
GREAT IDEAS- THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
WELL FORMED PROGRAMS OR- WHAT'S
WHAT'S THE MISSING PIECE. AND
HOW CAN WE HELP FILL IN THOSE
DAYS THAT THERE'S GAPS. YEAH
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT SUCH A
GREAT QUESTION- I THERE ARE
THERE ARE A NUMBER AND I'LL
JUST. I'LL TALK ABOUT A COUPLE-
ONE IS ALIGNMENT OF WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS- BOTH AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
SO WE DO HAVE A OF A LARGE
INVESTMENT IN EDUCATION FOR ANY
WORK FOR SERVICES IN THE STATE-
IT AMOUNTS TO ABOUT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY- AND- BUT- A
BIG CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING VERY DIRECTLY BOTH
THE IN SACRAMENTO. AND AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IS THE ALIGNMENT
AMONG ALL THOSE DIFFERENT SORT
OF- INITIATIVES PROGRAMMES AND
INTERVENTIONS. SO THAT WE'RE
GETTING GREATER SCALE AND
IMPACT OF THOSE OUT SO THAT
MEANS- WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH OUR PARTNERS INSIDE THE
LABOR AGENCY BECAUSE WE HAVE
THREE DIFFERENT APARTMENTS FOR
RATHER INSIDE LABOR YOU SEE
THAT ARE- IN CHARGE OF
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS OF
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT- AND- YOU
MAY HAVE SEEN THE PROPOSAL IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR NEW-
NEED WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. I'M SO THAT'S ONE
WAY. AT THE STATE LEVEL BUT
ALSO WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
OUR PARTNERS IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE BECAUSE A
LARGE SAID INVESTMENT. IN
SKILLS TRAINING IS ACTUALLY
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE COLLEGE
SYSTEM. INSERT AND IS WELL AS
OTHER DEPARTMENTS THAT THAT.
MANAGE AND ADMINISTER WHAT
FIRST DOLLARS. AND WE DON'T DO
THAT BECAUSE WE- BECAUSE WE
PROVIDE SERVICES FROM
SACRAMENTO IN FACT ALL THE
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED LOCALLY
AT THE POINT OF SERVICE
DELIVERY WHERE PEOPLE MOST NEED
HELP AND WHAT BUSINESSES NEED
HELP. SO THAT ALIGNMENT IN
SACRAMENTO IS GOING TO HELP-
MAKE THE ALIGNMENT ON THE
GROUND AMONG SERVICES. MORE
SEAMLESS SO THAT COMPANIES AND
WORKERS. ARE FACING NOT A
COMPLEX PATCHWORK OF PROGRAMS
BUT ACTION BUT INSTEAD. A
NAVIGABLE KIND OF MORE SEAMLESS
I WORK FOR SYSTEM THAT THEY CAN
GET THE MOST BENEFIT FROM SO I
THINK THE FIRST ONE IS IT IS
ALIGNMENT THE SECOND ONE IS.
SIX BILLION DOLLARS SOUNDS LIKE
A LOT BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH-
CALIFORNIA'S A THREE TRILLION
DOLLAR ECONOMIES WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT WAYS TO REALLY SMARTLY.
INVEST MORE DOLLARS I THINK
THIS STIMULUS IS GONNA GIVE US
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY. TO INVEST
IN THINGS THAT WE KNOW WILL
WORK BEST NOT LIKE THESE HIRING
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS- IN
ADDITION TO THAT. BECAUSE WORK
TARGETING UP UP. POPULATIONS
THAT ARE MOST VULNERABLE- WE
NEED TO BE. ABLE TO INVEST IN
WHAT WE CALL SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES- SO TRAINING PROGRAMS
ARE REALLY GREAT THEY'RE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT OUT SOME
OF THE BEST APPRENTICESHIP.
BUT- BUT WORKERS WHO ARE.
SUPPORTING FAMILIES AND TRYING
TO PAY BILLS. I DON'T HAVE THE
LUXURY. OF SETTING ALL THAT
ASIDE AND GOING TO A TRAINING
PROGRAM SO WHAT WE NEED TO
INVEST MORE IN AND THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH OF THIS NOW- IN THE
SUPPORT OF SERVICES THAT
INCLUDE INCOME SUPPORTS FOR
THOSE WORKERS SO THEY CAN STAY.
IN TRAINING AND BENEFIT FROM
THAT- AND GET ACCESS TO GOOD
QUALITY JOB- IT ALSO OTHER
KINDS OF SUPPORTS LIKE
TRANSPORTATION HELP- CHILD CARE
ASSISTANCE- HELP WITH TOOLS AND
MATERIALS- AT. HOUSING ALL OF
THOSE THOSE KINDS OF THINGS WE
NEED TO REALLY INVEST IN BUT IN
CONTEXT OF A QUALITY TRAINING
THAT'S LEADING TO A GOOD
QUALITY JOBS. THANKS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER ANY
FURTHER PRESENTATION IN REGARDS
TO THE WORK FORCE OF OUR
DEVELOPMENT YOU JUST MENTION IT
COMES TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEVEL THE LOCAL LEVEL AND WE
TRAIN THEM FOR THE JOBS THAT
ARE THERE AND MY DISTRICT ITS
AIRLINE MECHANICS AIRLINES
AIRFRAME OF. REPAIRS AND WITH
THE CONSTRUCTION PEOPLE OF THE
STATE CONSTRUCTION THERE'S
HUNDREDS OF JOBS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. THAT
THEY ARE TRAINED FOR AND
EVERYBODY KNOWS IF YOU CALL A
PLUMBER IT'S TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO GET YOUR DRAIN
CLEARED. BUT THEY WERE TRAINING
THOSE PEOPLE FOR THOSE JOBS
THAT ARE RIGHT THERE LOCALLY
AND I'D LIKE TO SEE MORE
FUNDING TO MAKE SURE YOU HAVE
THE RESOURCES THAT YOU HAVE
THERE. ANOTHER ONE IS A SOLAR
ENERGY FIELDS AT UP THERE'S A
BIG INDUSTRY RIGHT NOW. IS
TRAINING THOSE FOR MAKING THE
MANUFACTURING OF THE SOLAR
PANELS AND MAINTENANCE OF THE
SOLAR PANELS AND OF COURSE
ELECTRIC ELECTRICITY GRID. THAT
WOULD BE UPGRADED SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
TRYING TO GET YOU ALL THIS.
REVENUE AND RESOURCES THAT YOU
NEED SO WE GET IT BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL. THANK YOU JOHN
NUMBER. THANK YOU MISTER SMITH
I DO I KNOW THAT WE HAVE ONLY A
COUPLE MINUTES LEFT HERE AND I
DO WANT TO MAYBE AND A WITH.
SOME OF OUR COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGES YOU KNOW WHAT ARE
CALIFORNIA'S. GREATEST STRENGTH
IN TERMS OF WORK FORCE IF YOU
COULD DYE SHIRT US BE ADVISED.
MR ANY. SUCH A GREAT QUESTION-
MANY- WE HAVE OUR GREAT
UNIVERSITIES GREAT STE. CSU AND
UC WE HAVE THE STRONGEST SYSTEM
COMMITTEE COLLEGES I THINK INS
IN THE COUNTRY- COMMITTEE
COLLEGES SAVE MY LIFE- THEIR
ACCESSIBLE- BUT TRAINING IS
INEXPENSIVE. AND IT'S JUST A
REALLY HIGH QUALITY SYSTEM WE
HAVE REALLY STRONG LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS
AROUND THE STATE. WHOSE ROLE IS
SIMILAR TO OURS AT THE STATE
LEVEL OF COORDINATING ALL THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
AND CONNECTING THOSE TO WHAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN LABOR
MARKETS WITH BUSINESSES- WE
HAVE STRONG. PARTNERSHIPS WITH
OUR MANUFACTURING ASSOCIATION
BANK MANUFACTURING COMPANIES
AROUND THE STATE WE HAVE REALLY
STRONG PARTNERSHIPS WITH- THE
TRADES TO THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES COUNCIL THE LOCAL
BUILDING TRADES COUNCILS- I
MEAN THE STRENGTHS ARE
MANIFOLD. AND OF COURSE
CALIFORNIA'S INCREDIBLY DIVERSE
ECONOMY. AND I THINK THAT'S A
CHALLENGE ALSO BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO BE SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL ACROSS THE
STATE THAT THE CHALLENGES IN
FRESNO ARE VERY DIFFERENT THAN
THE CHALLENGES. ARE IN SANTA
CLARA SO- THAT DIVERSITY IS A
GREAT STRENGTH. BUT IT'S ALSO-
MAKE IT. REQUIRES OF TWO BILLS
TO BE REALLY DELIBERATE THAT WE
DON'T DRIVE EVERYTHING FROM
SACRAMENTO BUT WE INVEST IN
PARTNERSHIPS BETTER SECTOR
BASIN THAT A REGIONAL.
WONDERFULLY PART WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND- YOUR
PARTNERSHIP AS WE ARE LOOK AT
HOW WE CAN CONTINUE INVESTING.
AND IN GREAT QUALITY JOBS AS
YOU STATED HI. THANK YOU FOR
THIS SEGMENT OF OUR PANEL WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT AGENDA ITEM. IF THE
SPEAKERS FOR OUR NEXT PANEL-
KIDS PLEASE AND MEET THEIR
MIKES AND OPEN THEIR VIDEO
STUDY- WELL THEY GET ORGANIZED
I DO WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE
THAT WILL BE TAKING PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. AFTER FOLLOWING THIS
PANEL- THIS AGENDA ITEM AND LET
ME GO AHEAD AND JUST READ OFF
THE NUMBER. BUT YOU CAN CALL IN
FOR PUBLIC TESTIMONY THAT IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE. FIVE SEVEN. SO WE
ARE PLEASED TO WELCOME WINE
TASTINGS PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION. WE HAVE
RON MILLER THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR LOS ANGELES ORANGE
COUNTY'S BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
AND WE HOW TRACY STANHOPE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
INDIAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE OF
CALIFORNIA. RATHER THAN HAVE
ANOTHER ROUND OF PRESENTATIONS
WE WILL JUST DO A QUICK ROUND
OF Q. AND H. WE ADDRESS EACH OF
OUR PANELISTS TO MAKE A BRIEF
TWO MINUTE INTRODUCTION. WHICH
WILL THEN BE FOLLOWED BY
QUESTIONS IN A DIALOGUE WITH
THE COMMITTEE MISTER HASTIE AND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO START US OFF
WITH THE WORD ABOUT YOURSELF IN
YOUR ORGANIZATION STE STE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MANAGED
CARE MEMBERS REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
PLATFORM. TO SHARE VOIGTS
ACTUALLY FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
A YEAR AND I THINK WE'LL ALL
REMEMBER TODAY IS A ONE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF WHEN THE
GOVERNOR. ISSUED THE- SHELTER
IN PLACE ORDER FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S MOMENTOUS BECAUSE
WE'RE STILL SEEN OUR WAY
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC IN THE
EFFECT IT'S HAD ACROSS OUR
ECONOMY IT. IS OBVIOUSLY
PALPABLE AND WE'RE WE'RE TRYING
TO GET THROUGH A SEPARATE STATE
THAT. COMMENTARY FOR MISTER YOU
ARE MISTER RANEY BEFORE BECAUSE
THAT SETS THE STAGE. FOR WHERE
WE'RE AT AT THE MOMENT SO I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. OR A HUNDRED THREE
YEAR OLD TRADE ORGANIZATION-
PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
LEGISLATIVE AND REGULATORY
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF. OF THE
MANUFACTURING SECTOR OUR
MEMBERS ARE THE SMALL MEDIUM
AND LARGE MANUFACTURES THAT
MAKES. MOST OF THE PRODUCTS
THAT YOU ENGAGE WITH- IN YOUR
DAILY LIVES AND WORK LIVES IT
CENTRO- THEY WANT TO QUESTION
THE ONE THAT WE WERE ASKED TO
FOCUS ON IT YOU KNOW HOW MANY
OF WE SERVICE. DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
A BIG NUMBER- BECAUSE WE
LAUNCHED A- P. P. CONSORTIUM
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION LAST
JUNE. AND SINCE THAT TIME TO BE
CONNECTED. AND CAMP THEY HAD
PEOPLE VISIT OUR WEBSITE OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND TIMES. AND SO
WE ARE SERVING AS MUCH OF THE
COMMUNITIES WE POSSIBLY CAN. AS
MAKERS. OF NONMEDICAL PP AND
THE PROGRAM IS AROUND SUCCESS.
IT TOOK A FEW MONTHS GET OUT OF
THE GROUND THE ONE WE DID
REALLY GET GROUND. I WE
PARTICIPATE AT CM CA DOES IN
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
I WOULD MISTER RANEY. AND I
RECENTLY I CONCLUDED MY SERVICE
AS A MEMBER OF THE FUTURE WORK
COMMISSION. MY WORKSTREAM IN
THAT AREA WAS ON THE QUALITY.
OF THE JOB QUALITY INDEX- THAT
I WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE U.
F. C. W. ON. AND REAL PROUD
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE IF WE'RE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE CAN'T PROVIDE
QUALITY JOBS TO OUR- RESIDENTS
WERE KIND OF MISSING THE PLOT
WE DO HAVE THE BEST STATE. IN
THE NATION AND LOOKING OUTSIDE
RIGHT NOW I CAN TELL YOU
PROBABLY IN THE PAST WHETHER
THE COUNTRY. AT THE MOMENT. WE
HAVE A LARGE SCALE OF CAPABLE-
SKILLED EMPLOYEES THAT WE JUST
NEED TO MAKE SURE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED AND
THRIVE. IN THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE- QUESTIONS THAT COME WE
HAVE A LOT TO SAY AND I DO
APPRECIATE AGAIN OF THE
PLATFORMS FOR SERVICE I WANTED
TO DO THIS AT YOUR CERVANTES WE
REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
HASTINGS I DO JUST I WANT TO
REMIND OUR. CALLERS WHO WILL BE
CALLING FOR PET PUBLIC HAS. TO
WIND UP IN THE QUEUE AND THAT
NOW AGAIN IS A SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT FIVE SEVEN. BUT LET
ME GO AHEAD AND- IN. MR MILLER.
WHAT CAN MILLER YOU LIKE TO
INTRODUCE. OF THE WITH THE LOS.
COUNTY ABILITY NICK AND I TRY
COUNCIL. GOOD MORNING. WHAT'S
GOOD MORNING MADAM. AND- A
MEMBERS. I'M NOT MILLER I'M THE
EXACT SEARCH OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY TRADE. WELL WE WERE UP
ABOUT A HUNDRED FOR FIVE
SKILLED TRADE MEN WOMEN IN L.
IN ORANGE. I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE BUILDING. TODAY WHERE
THEY WERE UP A TOTAL OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEN AND WOMEN
IN THE STATE. AND THAT INCLUDES
SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND
APPRENTICES IN THE STATE KNOWS
APPRENTICES ARE PART OF A JOINT
LABOR MANAGEMENT APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM. SO WE ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF WORKING MEN AND WOMEN
EACH AND EVERY DAY. AND THAT
NON UNION AND UNION. WELL WE
WANT TO SEE AND WORKERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- HAVE A
GOOD SAFE. NONPRODUCTIVE JOBS
IN THE STATE SO WE ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF ALL WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN. WE'RE BUILDING A SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE OF
TOMORROW. AND IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT WITH ALL THE BABY
BOOMERS THAT ARE RETIRING. WE
HAVE ADEQUATE TRAINING PROGRAMS
IN PLACE. TO SUPPLEMENT THAT
EFFORT. AND I THINK IN YOUR
PACKET TODAY. YOU'LL SEE A
REPORT ON THE SHIP READINESS
PROGRAM REPORT. THIS THIS IS
JUST PERTAINING TO LA IN ORANGE
COUNTY. BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT MANY SUCH PROGRAMS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE- OCCURRING
WITHIN THE BUILDING TRADES. AND
LIKE- ONE OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER SAID EACH AREA HAS ITS
OWN. OIL LOGISTICS AND- NEEDS.
THIS IS A PRETTY SHAPE TO WHAT
WE NEED HERE IN LA AND ORANGE
COUNTY. AND I WANT TO THANK HIM
RAINY I SEE HE WAS ON THE ON
THE- PROGRAM TODAY. HE WAS VERY
INSTRUMENTAL IN WORKING WITH US
TO GET THIS THING SET UP. BUT
THE- WE TO- HAVE PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THE WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT BOARDS WELL BOND
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE COUNSELS.
PLANNING COMMISSIONS AND- WE
ALSO PARTNER WITH A LOT OF
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE FROM COLLEGES.
WE'RE DOWN TO UP K. THROUGH
TWELVE INSTITUTIONS. AND ALSO A
BIZ FED CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE
CENTRAL LABOUR BODIES SO WE'RE
INVOLVED TRAINING IS A OUR MAIN
FOCUS BECAUSE WE HAVE TO WE
HAVE TO TRAIN THE WORKFORCE FOR
THE WORK THAT'S COMING UP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MILLER. BUT IF WE CAN HAVE A
STAND OFF IF YOU COULD PLEASE-
MAKE AN INTRODUCTION AND TELL
US MORE ABOUT THE AMERICAN
INDIAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. IF
YOU'RE WOMAN. WILL SERVE ON
TAPE HELLO I'M TRACY STAND OFF
AND PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
INDIAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE CELEBRATING
OUR TWENTY SIX YEAR THIS THIS
THIS TWENTY IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE HERE- I HAVE TO SAY
HELLO TO JAMES RAMOS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YOUR TRIBE WAS THE FIRST
TRIED TO JOIN OUR CHAMBER ARBOR
REPRESENT THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN
INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVE IN TRIBAL
ENTERPRISES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AND WE ALSO RUN ON
THE LARGEST AMERICAN INDIAN UP
PROCUREMENT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTER IN THE
COUNTRY WE SERVE TWO HUNDRED
SIX TRIBESMEN AGAIN THOUSANDS
OF AMERICAN INDIAN ALASKAN
NATIVE. AND TRIBAL ENTERPRISES
AND IT I AM A FORMER TRIBAL
CHAIRWOMAN OF THE PRAIRIE BAND
POTAWATOMI NATION AND CANCELS
ALTHOUGH I'M A NATIVE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND HAVE OWNED A
BUSINESS YEAR FOR THIRTY THREE
YEARS NOW WE DO ADVERTISE IN.
THE GRAPHICS TOLD AT PRO. SO
HAVE A VERY REAL PER OR WITH
THIRTY. ARE OUR GOAL IS
ECONOMIC SELF SUFFICIENCY
THROUGH OUR PEOPLE THROUGH OUR
ENTERPRISE OWNERSHIP AND- WHERE
WHERE WE'RE DOING IT WE'RE
MAKING IT HAPPEN. WE ARE VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE. JUST A
GREAT- SLADE OF TRIBES AND
PARTNERS THROUGHOUT CORPORATE
AMERICA GOVERNMENT ENTITIES AND
ART AND ART AND OUR MEMBERS
WERE WERE RUN BY- AMERICAN
INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVE OWNED
BUSINESSES OR WHO ARE AT THE
CORE OF OUR OUR- OUR GROUP AND-
WE'RE- WE'RE AGAIN MAKING IT
HAPPEN FOR PEOPLE. WE HAVE A
LOT OF. OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR PUSHING FOR
PROCUREMENT OPPORTUNITIES WERE
REALLY HOPING THE STATE CAN
CONTINUE TO OPEN UP WITH.
SAFELY WITH KOBE AND- PROTOCOLS
THAT- ARE VERY NECESSARY WE'VE
BEEN WORKING FOR THE LAST YEAR
WE'VE DONE HUNDREDS OF WEBINARS
AND BUSINESS CAPACITY BUILDING
BUILDING INITIATIVES BUT WE
NEED TO GET BACK IN PERSON WE
NEED TO GET THE STATE ROLLING.
AND WE NEED TO HELP OUR PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO GROW AND- AGAIN
ACHIEVE ECONOMIC SELF
SUFFICIENCY THROUGH BUSINESS
OWNERSHIP AND POORER PEOPLE AND
OTHERS. HAVE HOLY DARSHAN INNER
CHAMBER ALONE OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND TO SIXTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO ARMED WORK WORSE. WERE SMALL
MINORITY BUT WE'RE PRETTY DARN
MY IDEAS AS THE WE'RE REALLY
HAVING A GREAT TIME DOING THIS
AND HELPING OUR PEOPLE SO THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY
AND I APPRECIATE. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
FOR ME ALL THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
A STAFF FOR BEING HERE THIS
MORNING WITH US AND DIED SO
CURRENT ENCOURAGING TO HEAR
THEY WITH THE WORK THAT THE
AMERICAN INDIAN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IS DOING THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. I LET ME GO AHEAD
AND OPEN IT UP WITH THAT MAYBE
A COUPLE QUESTIONS AND THEN
TURN IT OVER TO. OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ARE FOR ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. IF I MAY BE MY OUT
FROM HIS WE COULD DO START THE
YEAR HERE IS THE MOST SINGLE
MOST IN. ACT THE STATE CAN'T. I
TO. A SUCCESSFUL. RECOVERY AND
IF YOU CAN ALSO WHILE WE'RE AT
IT SHARE WHAT YOUR
ORGANIZATION'S ECONOMIC
RECOVERY PRIORITIES ARE FOR
THIS YEAR. THE SINGLE MOST
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION BECAUSE
THE SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT THE STATE CAN DO IS
PROVIDE ACCESS TO CAPITAL. AND
OF THE FORGIVABLE LOANS AND THE
GRANTS ARE GREAT- WE HAVEN'T
SEEN A LOT OF THEM BEING
AWARDED TO OUR PEOPLE THOUGH
UNFORTUNATELY AT TIMES- THE
LATEST ROUND OF THE PPP LOAN I
KNOW IT'S A FEDERAL PROGRAM.
WITH THE 25% CRITERIA HAS
REALLY LIMITED US TO ACCESS TO
CAPITAL- SO THAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING BECAUSE OF THE
FACT THAT- THE STATE HAS BEEN
CLOSED THERE'S REVENUE THERE
THAT WE WILL NEVER EVER MAKE
UP. SO PEOPLE TALK ABOUT LOANS
AND OTHER THINGS WELL YOU HAVE
TO HAVE BUSINESS TO GET LOANS
OPPORTUNITY RUBBING ELBOWS
CONTINUE TO BUILD THE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT NEED TO BE
BUILT TO BUILD- OPPORTUNITIES
AND OPTION CONTRACTS IN THE
WARD. FOR PEOPLE IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO US RIGHT NOW-
WE'RE REALLY IN FOCUS ONCE WE
GET OUT OF THIS WE HOPE ON A BY
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE. WHERE WE
CAN ENCOURAGE- YOU FOLKS TO
HELP US ENCOURAGE STATE
AGENCIES AND COMPANIES TO
CONTINUE THE BY CALIFORNIA- WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST COST OF LIVING
IN THE COUNTRY. AND WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST UTILITY RATES IN THE
COUNTRY AND- ARE YOU KNOW OUR
SALARIES ARE. HIGH TOO SO WE TO
MAINTAIN COMPETITIVENESS- WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON PUTTING THE
MONEY BACK INTO OUR COMMUNITIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WITH PHIL-
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE MAJOR
THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON. A GERMAN- THIS IS REALLY
MAKING SURE THAT OUR PEOPLE-
EQUIPPED TO DO BUSINESS AND
CONTINUE TO DO BUSINESS BUT WE
NEED TO GET BACK TO US AND WE
NEED TO DO IT SAFELY SO ONE OF
THE- GREATEST- ISSUES THAT
WE'VE HAD IS PEOPLE NOT PREPARE
ENOUGH FOLLOWING THE- COALBED.
SAFETY PROTOCOLS AND- YOU KNOW
MASKING UP CALVET AMERICAN
INDIANS HAVE REALLY BEEN
FIGHTING THIS DISEASE AND IT'S
A VERY SAD WE HAVE THE ONE OF
THE HIGHEST DEATH RATES AND
INCIDENCE OF THE COVETED.
INFECTION IN THE COUNTRY SO-
BEEN REALLY. JUST MASS UP IN
SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO HELP
OUR PEOPLE. AND CONTINUE TO
TAKE CARE OF OUR CALL. AND CAN
TO OFFER BUSINESS IN THE BEST
WAY WE CAN SEE FIT. TO MAINTAIN
THROUGH THIS- AND IT'S BEEN
TOUGH I WILL TELL YOU IT'S NOT
EASY. FOR ANY OF US TO CONTINUE
ON THIS PROCESS SO. ANYTHING
YOU GUYS CAN DO TO HELP US-
REBUILD AND TOUCH THROUGH WITH
CAPITAL. ACCESS IS. REALLY
APPRECIATED- AND THE STATE
PROGRAM WERE PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
RELIEF BRANCH. THAT'S BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL BUT I BELIEVE
THERE'S JUST BEEN A LOW AMOUNT
OF OUR PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO IT.
TO GET GET THAT- THAT
BACKGROUND AND I THINK
L'INDUSTRIE STRONGER TREMENDOUS
PROGRAM AND I CAN'T I CAN'T
COMMIT IN THE MANAF- BUT THAT
AL GORE AND WE'D LIKE TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
THAT ALGORITHMS SO WE CAN HELP
OUR PEOPLE. ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS PERHAPS A LITTLE MORE
STRATEGICALLY SO WE CAN- UP TO
MORE OF THOSE GRANTS FOR FOLKS
IN ROUNDS FIVE AND SIX. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ONE NOTED. HI IF
I COULD HAVE POSED THE SAME
QUESTION TO MR MILLER JUST FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE WHAT IS THAT
PROP SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT
ACTION THAT THE STATE CONTAINS.
THE STATE CAN TAKE ARE TO
SUPPORT. THE SUCCESSFUL
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. TO RESTORE
MR MILLER ON. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES YES WE CAN OKAY WE
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL- BRING BACK
THE ECONOMY WE'VE BEEN VERY
LUCKY IN THE CONSTRUCTION
TRADES. TO US STAY RELATIVELY
BUSY. DUE TO OUR TRAINING AND-
ABILITY TO ADHERE TO THE
PROTOCOLS THAT WERE PUT IN
PLACE BY THE CDC. WE WERE ABLE
TO KEEP A LOT OF CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS OPEN. OUR OUR MEN AND
WOMEN ARE ABLE TO. USE THE
PROPER PPD AND WORK ON THE
PROJECTS RELATIVELY SAFELY. BUT
WE'RE CONCERNED. WITH THE
COMING OUT OF THIS IS NOT A
DOWNTURN IN THE ECONOMY. THAT-
WE GET THINGS GROWING OUR
TRAINING PROGRAMS ARE KIND OF
HAVE BEEN PUT ON HIATUS BECAUSE
THE CLASSROOM. YEAH THE ABILITY
TO GET INTO A CLASSROOM. BOB
WHAT WE SPEND TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR TRAINING
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
APPRENTICES. WE'RE STARTED
STICK OUR TOE BACK IN THE WATER
GETTING APPRENTICESHIPS OPEN
BACK UP. REALLY BEEN SORT OF
ONLINE- BUT THE HANDS ON THAT'S
REQUIRED IN THE CLASSROOMS
HASN'T REALLY BEEN TAKEN PLACE
SO IT'S GOING TO START. WHEN IT
COMES TO. THE FUTURE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS WHERE IT'S AT.
AND WHILE WE'RE UP ALL IN ON
THE ELECTRIFICATION. AND THE
GREENING OF THE NEW WORLD. WE
CAN'T MAKE THE MISTAKES OF PAST
PRACTICE AND LEAVE TECHNOLOGY
AND INDUSTRY BEHIND LET'S THEIR
IN PLACE ALREADY WE HAVE TO
HELP IT ADAPT AND I'M TALKING
ABOUT OIL AND GAS I'M TALKING
ABOUT ENERGY. AND I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE WATER YOU KNOW AS YOU
KNOW WE LIVE IN A DESERT WATER
IS VERY PRECIOUS TO US IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE TO HAVE.
A MUTUAL FUND WATER CONVEYANCE
ENERGY CONVEYANCE AND- ALSO WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS SO I WOULD ASK-
THE IMPORTANT THING IS FOR
POLICY MAKERS IN SACRAMENTO.
WHEN YOU CREATE THE BILL'S ASK
YOURSELF. HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT THIS BILL IS GOING TO
PROMOTE GOOD. A SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE. SO THAT WE
CAN GET PEOPLE BACK TO WORK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AYE MR MILLER
LET ME TO QUICKLY TURN IT OVER-
TO MISTER HASTINGS FOR THAT
SAME QUESTION BUT IF YOU CAN
ALSO. PERHAPS ANSWER FROM YOUR
ORGANIZATION'S PERSPECTIVE WHAT
HAVE BEEN THE THREE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES. ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY IS GONNA SOUND
CLICHE- BUT THE BEST THING THAT
THE STATE CAN DO AT THIS MOMENT
IS TO GROW THE PIE. AND THAT IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE ECONOMY
IS PUT ON A PATTERN OF GROWTH
SO THAT WE CAN EXPAND AND MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY IS LISTED I
VIDAK: BACK GROWING PART IN IT
IT DOES SOUND CLICHE BUT IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT. WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY HOW WE'RE GONNA COME
OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC LET ALONE
WENT- AND HOPE IS NOT A
STRATEGY OF HOPING THAT THERE'S
THIS MIRACULOUS ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY THAT SPENT TEN TOP IT
JUST RELEASES ITSELF SO WHAT WE
CAN DO. TOGETHER WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
IS THAT YOU KNOW CAN INCREASE
OUR LOSS AS IT WERE AND I'M
GLAD THAT THE PREVIOUS TWO
SPEAKERS MENTIONED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CAPITAL.
BECAUSE THE MTA'S TOP
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY THIS
SESSION IS ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
OH FOUR WHICH WOULD PROVIDE AN
INVESTMENT CREDIT FOR
MANUFACTURING CAPITAL AND IT
WOULD VARY AMONG THE SIZE OF
MANUFACTURED SO WOULD ACTUALLY
REWARD SMALLER MANY FACTS
WITHIN A SLIGHTLY LARGER
INCENTIVE THAN. THE LARGER
MANUFACTURER AND HAVING THAT ON
THE BOOKS IS A CLEAR SIGNAL
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT MANUFACTURERS AND IS A
CRITICAL PART OF THE MONEY AND
ONE THAT'S BEEN ABLE TO REMAIN
LARGELY OPEN AS MR MILLER
INDICATED- DURING THE LAST
MONTH NOT EASILY I WILL TELL
YOU BUT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
REMAIN OPEN. A LOT OF OUR
MEMBERS FALL WITHIN THE
CRITICAL MANUFACTURING
DESIGNATION AND THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE TO KEEP THEIR OPERATIONS
GOING BUT IT IS ONLY WITH
ADDITIONAL PP AT THE WORK SITE
ADDITIONAL SEPARATION OF
EMPLOYEES AND ADDITIONAL
CHANGES IN OUR POLICIES AND
PRACTICES THAT HAVE. MADE. THAT
HAPPEN- BUT WE- IT AND WE BEEN
SIX- ALONG THE WAY THOUGH TRAIN
SEEMS BE A THEME THAT IS COMING
THROUGH FROM ALL OF THE
SPEAKERS. CURRENTLY THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL
EXISTENCE READY MADE IT'S BEEN
THERE FOR A LONG WHILE. AND
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS IT
HAS BEEN DECLINING IT IS
RESOURCES BE MADE AVAILABLE. IF
THERE IS A WAY THAT WE COULD
PROP THAT UP TO ENSURE. THAT
TRUCK THE FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE
IN FACT MORE FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE EACH YEAR. WOULD BE
FANTASTIC- BECAUSE THE MORE
SKILLED LABOR THAT WE HAVE IN
THE STATE IS GOING TO BENEFIT
OUR ECONOMY. BOTH IN THE NEAR
TERM BUT CERTAINLY IN THE IN
THE LONG TERM- FOR THE THREE-
IT'S I LOST ON THAT THE LAST
SECTION MANAGER. I THINK YOU
WANT TO FOCUS ON THE- THAT OUR
THREE PRIORITIES. SO IF YOU
COULD JUST MAYBE SHARE IT- SO
THE THREE CHILD MAYBE
CHALLENGES THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
AT HERE. AS AN ORGANIZATION.
OKAY THE CHALLENGES IT IS AN
UNKNOWN FUTURE- BUT WILL TURN
THAT INTO AN OPPORTUNITY IF WE
DO OUR JOBS CORRECTLY BY
ENGAGING WITH THE LEGISLATURE-
BUT I THINK AB I WANT TO GET
THIS POINTED AT LEAST AT SOME
POINT THIS MORNING AND THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE I THINK RIGHT
NOW IS MORE DYNAMIC AND
POLITICAL AND THAT IS THE
BINARY NATURE OF. THE POLITICAL
DISCOURSE IN THE IN THE COUNTRY
AND IT IS EITHER A RIGHT OR
WRONG YES OR NO- AT AT ASSEMBLY
LEFT OR RIGHT WE NEED TO FIND A
WAY TO HAVE A DISCOURSE WHERE
WE CAN BRING ISSUES TO THE
TABLE DISCUSS THEM AND FIND THE
BEST PATHWAY FOR SUCCESS AND-
ALL PLEDGE YOU KNOW OUR
ENGAGEMENT ENACTED IN THAT
DISCUSSION TO HOPEFULLY BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION NOT PART OF THE
PROBLEM. BUT IT'S JUST THAT THE
SOCIAL DISCOURSE HAS BECOME SO-
TO SIDE AND THAT I THINK WE'RE
MISSING SOME OPPORTUNITIES AS A
RESULT. THANK YOU SO MUCH IF I
COULD TURN IT OVER TO MR ALMOST.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS- ONE
FROM. RON- WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES- WHEN YOU TALKING ABOUT
THE CRITICISM THAT ARE GOING ON
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HOW WE
SEE- SECTORS. THAT HAVE- CALLED
ON A STRONGER DEMAND- DURING
THIS TIME AND DO YOU SEE THAT
DEMAND CARRYING FORWARD- INTO
THE COMING YEAR. SO YES I'M NOT.
WE'RE ANXIOUS TO GET UP FUTURE
PROJECTS STARTED BUT WE SEE AND
PRIVATE SECTOR MAYBE A SMALL
SLOWDOWN WELL PUBLIC WORKS IS
GONNA STILL GO VISITS THAT'S
RELATED TO BONDS. SO IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE OUR
EFFORT TRAINING BY THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL. BOB
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO THE
BUILDING TRADES ALSO. BECAUSE
OUR EMPLOYERS ARE MADE UP OF
EVERYTHING FROM A TWO TWO
PERSON SHOP TO MALTA YOU KNOW
FOUR HUNDRED FIVE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES AND TRAINING IS- AND
THAT HELPS THE EMPLOYERS THAT
THAT TRAINING PANEL AND- THEN
IT HASN'T BEEN FUNDED IN THE
PAST. FEW YEARS CORRECTLY IT'S
GONNA BE MORE IMPORTANT COMING
OUT OF THIS- DOWNTURN MORE THAN
EVER. MADAM CHAIR JUST FOLLOW
UP ON AND SO TO THAT DO WE SEE
THE APPRENTICE- PROGRAMS- UNION
NONUNION APPROACH- HIGHLY INTO
THE K. THROUGH. TWELVE FOR NOW.
SO IN OUR AREA WE'RE WE'RE UP
HEAVILY INVOLVED IN THE- WITH
L. A. U. S. T. WITH OUR
TRAINING PROGRAMS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WITH OUR TRAINING
PROGRAMS. BOB THE- FORMALLY
INCARCERATED PROGRAMS WE
PARTNER WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION- THE FLINT
RIDGE CENTER THESE ALL DEAL
WITH FORMERLY INCARCERATED
TALKS. AND THEN- WE CAN'T
FORGET ABOUT OUR VETERANS AND
MILITARY PERSONNEL COMING OUT
OF THE SERVICE. WE WANT TO FIND
THOSE- FOLKS GOOD CAREERS IN
THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES. AND I
THINK THE FUTURE IS BRIGHT-
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO SICKENING
UPPER STRUCTURE SONG AND WORK
TOGETHER ACROSS THE LINES. AND-
WE HAVE THE RIGHT PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON NOW SO-
INFRASTRUCTURE IS VERY
IMPORTANT YUP ELECTRIC CARS AND
THE GREEN CLIMATE ARE GREAT BUT
WE HAVE TO HAVE ROADS TO PUT
THOSE CARS ON OUR ROADS ARE IN
DISMAL SHAPE SO THAT WOULD NOT
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK- FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE. YOU TOO A LOT
OF JOB CREATION IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND THAT'S NOT A QUESTION FOR-
TRACY PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
INDIAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
WE'VE THE LEGISLATURE AND
WORKING WITH THE MINISTRATION
HAS APPROVED SO- BUSINESS
RELATED- GRAPHS. IS GRATTON HOW
TO APPLY FOR THOSE GRANTS-
TRANSLATING OVER INTO THAT-
INDIAN OWNED BUSINESSES HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF COMING IN
VERY WELL FOR US- WE'RE PART OF
THE TEAM THAT IS HELPING-
PEOPLE APPLY FOR THE GRANTS-
AGAIN EARLY CONCERN WAS WHAT
ARE THEY LOOKING FOR ON THAT
APPLICATION HOW DO IN BE MORE
STRATEGIC AND MAKING SURE THAT
OUR PEOPLE ARE BEING FOUND- SO
IT'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF A
CHALLENGE- WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE
A QUERY OF OUR MEMBERS TO SEE
HOW MANY HAVE GOTTEN- GRANT TO
APPLY FOR THEM AND SO FAR IT
ISN'T. REAL- DOESN'T LOOK GOOD
BUT- APPARENTLY THE RESULTS OF
ONE POINT 9% OF THE GRANTS WENT
TO NATIVE AMERICANS BUT- WE
DON'T KNOW YOU KNOW IF IT'S
BEEN TRULY EFFECTIVE FOR US-
BUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACCESS TO
CAPITAL AND- THESE GRANTS ARE.
VERY WELCOME- BECAUSE AS I SAID
EARLIER WHEN WITH THE SHUT DOWN
THE SLOWDOWNS WERE NEVER GOING
TO MAKE THE REVENUE BACK NONE
OF THE BUSINESSES ARE THAT
WE'VE LOST IN THE LAST YEAR OR
SO. AND INCOMES OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC WORK WE'RE STILL NOT
THERE YET SO. OF MY PANELISTS
AGREED SAYING THE TEACHERS ARE
KNOWN A LITTLE BIT FOR US- BUT
YOU KNOW WE'RE RESILIENT PEOPLE
WALK WILL WILL KEEP PLUGGING
ALONG THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. I THANK YOU AND-
THROUGH THE CHAIR IF THERE'S A
WAY THAT WE COULD- HIGHLIGHT
AND THROUGH THE COMMITTEE. AS
FAR AS WHAT'S- ADDRESSED IN
THOSE GRANTS AND HOW WE CAN GET
SOME OUT REACH OUT THERE AS FAR
AS FILLING OUT THOSE GRANTS TO
MAKING SURE THAT- WE HAVE-
PROMISE OF GETTING SOME OF
THOSE GRANTS BACK INTO THE-
INDIAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
WHETHER IT'S A SEMINAR WHETHER
IT'S SOME SOME TAKE TYPE OF
EDUCATIONAL- COMPONENT TO IT.
WE DEEPLY FOR. IT THANK YOU
CHAIR. YES MONITORED. MISTER
OMINOUS. LET ME GO AHEAD AND
TURN OVER TO MR SMITH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GREAT PRESENTE A
SMALL AS A RETIRED BUSINESS
OWNER AND A PAST CONTRACTOR
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. BUT
WHAT WE NEED TO DO ON
CALIFORNIA'S BESIDES HOUSING
AND INFRASTRUCTURE BUT I'D LIKE
TO ASK. MISTER HASTINGS AND MR
MILLER. HOW IS SEEK WELL
AFFECTED YOUR ORGANIZATION'S
EXPECTING CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
I KNOW IT TAKES FOREVER TO
BUILD ANOTHER LANE ON THE
HIGHWAY. A REBUILD THE LANE ON
THE HIGHWAY AND THEN I DO HAVE
A FOLLOW UP FOR OFFICES STAND
OFF WHEN WE'RE DONE. SO MAYBE
MISTER HASTINGS CAN GO FIRST.
IT IT YET THANK YOU- AND I'M
GONNA HAVE ADDRESSED THE
SITUATION BUT ALSO RAISE
ANOTHER ONE IT'S THIS UNIQUE TO
THE CURRENT CRISIS SO THE
SECRET PROCESS HERE CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN USED TO DELAY PROJECTS
OFTENTIMES WITHOUT ACTUALLY
GETTING THAT ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFIT THAT WAS INTENDED WHEN
THAT THE LAW WAS PASSED. AND
WITH THAT DELAY COMES AT A COST
IN BOTH IN THE FORMER
PERMITTING AND APPROVALS BUT
IT'S BEEN USED AS A TOOL TO
DELAY RATHER THAN TO ENGAGE- TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S AN
ENVIRONMENTAL. OF PROGRESS MADE
ON OTHER PROJECTS- THE BIGGER
CHALLENGE FIRST DURING A CRISIS
IS BEEN IN OUR VIEW THE OSHA
EMERGENCY STANDARDS THAT WERE
ADOPTED NINE MONTHS INTO THE
CRISIS AND HOW ARE IN FULL
EFFECT AND HAVE BEEN A
TREMENDOUS NEGATIVE.
CONSEQUENCE FOR OUR FACILITIES
THAT ARE OSHA COMPLAINT FROM
THE GET GO AND HALF PP AS A
MATTER OF COURSE IN OUR
FUNCTIONS ARE YOU CAN'T WALK
INTO A MANUFACTURING FACILITY
IF YOU'VE RECENTLY TOURED ONE
WITHOUT BE UNINVITED I
PROTECTION YOUR PROTECTION AND
SHE PROTECTION. FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR FEET UP WE'VE NOW ADDED
THE ELEMENT OF COURSE OF THE
MASK- AND ALL OF OUR FACILITIES
SO THE MANUFACTURING SECTOR
WAS. EASIER TO TAKE UP THE
ADDITIONAL PPE REQUIREMENTS BUT
WHENEVER WE ADD A LAYER OF
REGULATION THAT IS. CONSIDERED
TO BE UNIQUE AND SPECIFIC TO
THE CHALLENGE IT JUST ADDS TO
THE COMPLEX NATURE OF OUR WORK
WITHOUT. EVERYONE TAKEN AS AN
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY DOING I TENANTS IMAGE
THIS CRISIS OR ANY FUTURE
CRISIS SO THAT THE QUESTION
REALLY AB WELL THE ANSWER TO
YOUR QUESTION IS- BLESSES MORE
AND I THINK IF THERE'S A MORE
COOPERATIVE SPIRIT WHERE WE CAN
SIT DOWN YEAR ON A PER PROJECT
BASIS AND LOOK AT SEAQUEST. OR
ON THE MACRO THE OSHA STANDARDS
REALLY HAVE A REASONABLE
DISCUSSION AND FIND OUT REALLY
WHAT IS BEST FOR I EMPLOYERS
WORKERS AND ULTIMATELY
CALIFORNIA I THINK. WOULD BE A
GREAT WAY TO GO. THANK YOU. AND
MR MILLER. WELL STE STE SMOKING
UP UNDER THAT YES WAS IS ISSUE
IN STATE GETS STUCK BUILT. OUR
GOAL IS ALL TO- MAKE SURE THE
PHONE THAT WORK ON THESE. WELL
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT THE FOLKS THAT ARE
BUILDING THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CAN AFFORD TO LIVE IN ONE OF
UNITS. AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE- EVERYBODY HAS
GOOD WAGES. SAFETY ON THE
PROJECT HEALTHCARE AND A MODEST
PENSION AT THE AGE OF THIRTY
YEARS OF A CAREER. AND THAT'S
NOT TOO MUCH TO ASK EVERYBODY
SHOULD ONLY HAVE TO HAVE ONE
JOB. I'VE GOT FORTY TWO YEARS
IN THE PLUMBING TRADE. AND IT'S
AN ATRADIUS BANNED VERY GOOD TO
ME. IT'S NOT WHATEVER YOU PUT
INTO IT YOU'LL GET OUT OF IT.
BUT I WAS ABLE TO RAISE MY
FAMILY PUT MY KIDS THROUGH
SCHOOL. AND WE GOT A LOT OF
THOUGHT BUILT. AND EVERYBODY
SHOULD HAVE THAT SAME
OPPORTUNITY IN CALIFORNIA I
THINK OUR TRAINING PROGRAMS-
HELPED SHAPE THEM INDIVIDUALS
SO THAT THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO IT- BUT IT DOES
TAKE TOO LONG TO BUILD STUFF IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
NEED TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S GOOD LABOR STANDARDS
ATTACHED TO ALL OF THOSE-
POLICIES THANK YOU MR MILLER
THE OLD ADAGE IN CONSTRUCTION
AS YOU'RE DRIVING DOWN THE
HIGHWAY YOUR FAMILY GETS TIRED
TO SAY AND I BUILT THIS AND I
BUILT THAT BUT MOVING ON TO US
MRS OF STAND OFF WITH IT JUST
LIKE TO SEE IF YOU COME UP ON
THE SCREEN FIRST. HELLO OKAY
THERE WE GO WHAT DID YOU
MENTIONED THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
IS CAPITAL I'D LIKE TO WORK
WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU HAVE THE RESOURCES AND
INFORMATION TO GET IT OUT TO
YOUR MEMBERS IN THE CHAMBERS SO
THEY KNOW WHERE IT IS SO THEY
CAN APPLY FOR IT AND IF THEY
NEED HELP APPLYING FOR THAT
THAT WE HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS FOR THEM.
I APPRECIATE THAT SIR. WE DON'T
WE ARE PART OF THE TEAM AND
WE'VE BEEN DOING- THOUSANDS OF
CALLS HELPING PEOPLE. I THINK
THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE IS
WHAT IS THE CRITERIA ACTUALLY
FOR GETTING THIS RECORD. I
THINK OF THE FIRST LINE THEY
HAD- FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
REPORTED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF GRANTS GO OUT. WHICH
IF YOU LOOK AT IT JUST AS
AVERAGE OR WHAT THE GRANT WOULD
BE. FORTY TO FIFTY THOUSAND
BUSINESSES OUT OF FOUR MILLION
NUMBER CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES WOULD GET. SOME TYPE
OF GRANT. SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONCERN FOR US- WE JUST NEED TO
KNOW WHAT'S WHAT'S THE SECRET
SAUCE BASICALLY FORGETTING
GRANT. AND HOW DO WE POSITION
OUR BUSINESSES FOR REALLY-
GETTING THAT ALGORITHM THAT
SELECTING THESE BUSINESSES
RANDOMLY- SUPPOSEDLY TO- THEIR
ATTENTION. SO THANK YOU FOR
COMPUTER CONCERN AND- IT'S.
IT'S A CHALLENGE SO I WILL SAY
THAT. WE WILL WORK HARD FOR YOU
THANK YOU BECAUSE AS WE ALL SAY
WE'RE TALKING LOW INCOME
DIVERSITY PEOPLE OF COLOR YOU
ARE IN ALL OF THOSE CATEGORIES
SO YOU SHOULD BE RISING TO THE
TOP OF THE LEVEL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. TRANSCRIBING TURNER'S
THANK YOU I THANK YOU ALL FOR
AT FOR BEING HERE AND SHARING
YOUR PERSPECTIVE THIS IS BEEN A-
REALLY REALLY GOOD HEARING
THANK YOU CHAIR. I'M SO I WANT
TO COME BACK TO THE
CONVERSATION AROUND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND- RETRAINING I
KNOW THAT THAT SEEM TA AND THE
BUILDING TRADES ARE REALLY KEY
PARTNERS OF CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS.
BOTH OF YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR
SOME OF YOUR REMARKS. A NEED
FOR US TO INVEST MORE IN I'D IN
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANELS. ARE
THERE OTHER THINGS THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SEE US DOING TO
ACCELERATE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS ACROSS THE
STATE PARTICULARLY AT THIS
INCREDIBLY CRITICAL JUNCTURE.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY LET ME GO FIRST
MR MILLER. AND I WOULD ACTUALLY
WE HAD SECRETARY ACTUALLY SUED
OUT OF THE INTECH CENTER. I
WHICH IS A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP WITH CALIFORNIA
STEEL HAT COLLEGE AND AS A
MODEL- HAVING THAT TYPE OF
PROGRAM AND- OFFERED AROUND THE
STATE WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL.
RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
REPLICABLE THAT THE NEEDS FOR
TRAINING IN THE SOUTH PLANMAY
BE DIFFERENT THAN THE NEEDS AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT TO
IDENTIFY WITH THOSE NEEDS ARE
AND DEVELOP A PUBLIC PRIVATE.
PARTNERSHIP WOULD BE A GREAT
WAY TO GO BECAUSE IT RESIDES
YOU KNOW NOT FULLY WITHIN THE
GOVERNMENT BUT NOT FULLY
WITHOUT AND IT'S A PARTNERSHIP
IN ONE THAT IS PROVEN SUCCESS.
AND OUR MEMBER CALIFORNIA STEEL
INDUSTRIES AS A BIG BENEFACTOR
THAT BECAUSE THEY DONATED LAND
ADJACENT TO THEIR FACILITY. SO
IF WE COULD FIND OTHER PLACES
TO REPLICATE THAT MODEL TO SIT
ALONGSIDE ETP AND OTHER
TRAINING PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY
THE LOCAL LEVEL- THAT WOULD BE
A HUGE STEP FORWARD CMT IS
COMMITTED. TO MAKING THOSE
PROGRAMS HAPPEN- AS BEST WE CAN
BECAUSE THE NEEDS ARE LOCAL
IT'S YOU KNOW THE OLD CLICHE
ALL POLITICS IS LOCAL ALL
TRAINING IS LOCAL TO. AND THE
NEEDS OF THE DIFFERENT AROUND
THE STATE BUT ONCE WE IDENTIFY
WHAT THOSE ARE IN THE VARIOUS
REGIONS I THINK WE'RE OFF TO
THE RACES OF AND WE'RE REALLY
HAVING AN OPPORTUNITY TO TRAIN.
AS MANY CALIFORNIANS. SUPPORT
FOR SOME JOBS. CAN MR MILLER.
YEP I KNOW IT GOING TO GET OF
HEARING ABOUT IT BUT
INFRASTRUCTURE IS THE KEY AND-
UP. THE GREEN THE GREEN NEW
DEAL IN THE STATE. WE'RE ALL
ABOUT THAT WE'RE WE'RE THE
FOLKS IN THE BUILDING TRADES
THAT ARE BUILDING. THE SOLAR
FACILITIES OUT IN THE DOCTOR'S.
THE WINDMILLS UP ON THE
MOUNTAINS. UP WERE ALSO THE
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS THAT WORK
IN THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY.
AND DESPITE WHAT FOLKS SAY THE
OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY IS NOT
GOING ANYWHERE FOR QUITE A FEW
YEARS. WE'RE ALL WORKING HARD
TO DEVELOP THAT ALTERNATIVE
ENERGY SO THAT ONE DAY THAT
HAPPENS. BUT WE CAN'T LEAVE
BEHIND INDUSTRIES LIKE WE HAVE
IN THE PAST. MY DAD WORKED FOR
GENERAL MOTORS FOR THIRTY YEARS
AND NOW I WORK WITH POLITICIANS
IN THE CITY OF SOUTH GATE THAT
DON'T EVEN KNOW GENERAL MOTORS
CAR PLAN EVER EXISTED. WE'VE
HAD SO MUCH MANUFACTURING
BELIEVES. BECAUSE THE INDUSTRY
IS NOT HERE LIKE IT USED TO BE
WE HAVE TO WORK HARD. YEAH
RETAKING THE INDUSTRY HELPING
THEM- CHANGE THEIR BUSINESS
MODEL IF SO BE IT SO THAT THEIR
CLEANER. AND IT HERE TO-
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS BUT WE
HAVE TO DO IT IN A COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO WORK WE DON'T
RUN HIM OUT OF THE STATE.
BECAUSE ALL OF THOSE INDUSTRIES
THAT LEFT THAT ARE NOT HERE
ANYMORE WE CAN GO OUT OF
BUSINESS THEY LEFT AND WENT TO
ANOTHER STATE. SO WE HAVE TO. I
JUST ASK YOU TO KEEP THAT IN
MIND. WHEN YOU'RE UPLOADING
LEGISLATION TOGETHER. AND JUST
JUST ASK YOURSELF WHAT IT IS A
GONNA DO TO THE LOCAL ECONOMY
INTO THE LOCAL WORKFORCE WE
WANT TO TRAIN EACH AND EVERY
PERSON THAT WANTS TO GO TO WORK
IN CONSTRUCTION. BUT WE HAVE TO
HAVE CONSTRUCTION JOBS BEFORE
THE MODEL THE END OF THE DAY WE
HAVE TO HAVE THAT WAY. TO A
CAREER. EXCELLENT THANKS FOR
THAT AND I THINK WHAT WHAT I
HEAR YOU SAYING AND- I SPACE
CERTAINLY AGREE IS. AS WE ARE
WORKING TO ACHIEVE A
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE GOALS
THERE'S A TON OF OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO CREATE GREAT JOBS IN
CLEAN ENERGY AND GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE. BUT THAT'S NOT
GONNA HAPPEN OVERNIGHT AND SO
WE'VE GOT TO MANAGE. THAT SAID
THAT TRANSITION AND WE'VE GOT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
CREATING THAT PIPELINE OF GOOD
JOBS. AS THESE NEW INDUSTRIES
ARE EMERGING. SEPT I THINK IT'S
A SECOND EXCITING OPPORTUNITY
THANK. SERVICING INTERNATIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM ANY OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
WITH PUBLIC TESTIMONY AT THIS
TIME I WANT TO THANK EACH OF
OUR SPEAKERS. HI MISTER
HASTINGS MISTER MILLER MISS
STAND OFF FOR BEING WITH US
THIS MORNING AND- PROVIDING
THERE ARE YOUR PERSPECTIVE FROM
ENTERPRISE IT FROM AN
ORGANIZATION AND- WAYS THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS SOME OF OUR
CHALLENGES AND- I THANK YOU FOR
HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES AS WELL.
AS WE LOOK TO REBUILD A MORE
INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC- RECOVERY
AND SO THANK YOU TO EACH OF YOU
WE LOOK FORWARD TO. CONTINUE
BEING STRONG PARTNERS- AS WE
HEAD INTO THIS YEAR. LET ME GO
AHEAD AND- SHARE QUICKLY THE
ACCESS CODE. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
DILEEN IN DUTCH IS IT ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO- OH TWO. THE
NUMBER AGAIN IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FORTY TWO OH
TWO. SO PUBLIC TESTIMONY PUBLIC
COMMENT PORTION OF THE HEARING
WILL BEGIN. ARE FOR FOLKS
DIALING AND WE ASKED THIS IS A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE. WE
ASKED IF YOU CAN ELIMINATE ANY
BACKGROUND NOISE THAT DOES
INCLUDE MUTING YOUR LIVE
BROADCASTING YOUR SMARTPHONE
DEVICES TO REDUCE ANY SOUND
DISTORTION. FOR THOSE WHO WOULD
PREFER TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
COMMENTS THE COMMITTEE IS
ACCEPTING- THOSE UNTIL APRIL
FIFTEENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PLEASE SEND ANY WRITTEN
COMMENTS TO A- J. E. D. I.
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV. AGAIN
IF YOU CAN PLEASE- WE REQUEST
THAT EACH PERSON LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO TWO TO THREE
MINUTES- I'M MORE EXTENT
EXTENDED COMMENTS SHOULD BE
PROVIDED IN WRITING. OPERATOR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN WORKING
THROUGH THE CALLERS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOUR LINE NUMBER SEVEN YOU'RE
MY NUMBER'S CALLED PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD. ONCE
AGAIN PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
TO COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL. OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM NINE
FIFTEEN NINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OBJECT
RATHER ON BEHALF OF WORKER ON
RECOVERY CALIFORNIA A COALITION
OF THE STATE AND NATIONAL
WORKER OWNERSHIP EXPERIENCE
WE'RE GROWING BUSINESS IN
ORGANIZED LABOR ADVOCATING FOR
AN EQUITABLE AND INCLUSIVE
ECONOMY. WE BELIEVE THAT
PROMOTING AND FUNDING WORK ON
CONVERSION ACHIEVED MANY OF THE
STATED GOALS FROM ALEJO AND
DIRECTOR RAINY ABOUT EQUITY
MAINTAINING REVENUE IN THE
STATE AND LOCAL E. JOB QUALITY
STRENGTHENING WORKER VOICE AND
AGENCY AT WORK PLACE. AS WELL
WORK ESTIMATES THERE ARE EIGHT
HUNDRED WORK ON COMPANIES
ALREADY IN THE STATE. IN A
VIABLE BUSINESS RETENTION AND
THEY OFFERED VERSION STRATEGY
SHOULD BE MORE WIDESPREAD.
ACROSS OUR STATES FOR MILLION
SMALL BUSINESSES. J.
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF THAT'S PART AND
THE CHAIRS FOCUS ON EQUITY IN
IMPLEMENTATION OF SMALL
BUSINESS RELIEF PROGRAMS. AS
WELL OF THE AFFIRMATIVE
INCLUSION OF COOPERATIVE. AND A
TWO POINT ONE BILLION
ADDITIONAL FOR THE COVETED
RELIEF GRANT. AND THE LABOR
AGENCY SATISFIED OF A TENTH OF
THE FEET ENTREPRENEURSHIP FUNDS
FOR WORKER COOPERATIVES START
UPS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATION ON HOW
WE'RE GOING TO SHIFTED INTO THE
STATE'S OVERLAPPING. ECONOMIC
PRIORITIES FOR WORKERS
COMMUNITIES AND BUSINESSES
THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHRIS BOLLINGER ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR ETP
AND JOBS MY COMMENTS ARE IN
RELATION TO EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PANEL IN THE CUT PROPOSED IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET OUR
COALITION SUPPORTS JOB TRAINING
APPRENTICESHIPS AND CAREER
ADVANCEMENT FOR LABOR.
BUSINESSES AND EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS WE HAVE OVER FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS SIGNED ON IN
SUPPORT OF OUR EFFORT THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL IS
THE PREEMINENT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM IN STATE WE
ARE EXTREMELY CONCERNED WITH
PROPOSED 20% CUT T. T. P. THE
ADMINISTRATION AS YOU'RE
MARKING ADDITIONAL THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. IN YET E. T. P.
FACES A TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
CUT ETP'S ROLE IN THE WORK
FORCE AN ECONOMY IS MOVING
LARGE NUMBERS OF UNEMPLOYED
WORKERS QUICKLY INTO EMPLOYMENT
IN SAVING THE JOBS THREATENED
WITH DISPLACEMENT WE CANNOT
THINK OF A MORE WORTHWHILE
INVESTMENT GIVEN THE ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY OUR STATE IS
FACING. AS SUCH WE ARE
REQUESTING AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ETP. IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THANK YOU.
NINE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRWOMAN CERVANTES AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS WENDY BROWN VICE
PRESIDENT OF RESEARCH AND
POLICY AT AXION OPPORTUNITY
FUND A NONPROFIT SMALL BUSINESS%
LENDER AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION OR CDFI. AND ONE OF
THE LARGEST EITHER CALIFORNIA
STATE MALL BUSINESS CREDIT
INITIATIVES AT THE CCI PROGRAM
FOLLOWING THE GREAT RECESSION
WE KNOW FIRST HAND HOW
TRANSFORMATIVE THE FEDERAL FUND
CAN BE TO ENSURE CDFI OTHER
LENDERS PROVIDE CAPITAL TO
SMALL BUSINESSES OWNED BY
PEOPLE OF COLOR WOMEN. AND
OTHER UNDER INVESTED POPULATION.
THAT COULD SECOND AND
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE SIZEABLE
ROUND OF SSEC I FUNDING THROUGH
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE ACCESS TO CAPITAL FOR
UNDER ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS IN THE
MONTHS AND YEARS AHEAD. HE
GATHER WE CAN REPLICATE AND
BUILD ON CALIFORNIA'S SUCCESSES
AS ONE OF THE STATE WITH THE
HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF AFFECT
BCI FUNDING GOING TO BUSINESSES
AND LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS FOLLOWING THE
GREAT RECESSION. IT DO SO WE
ENCOURAGE POLICYMAKERS TO
SUPPORT EXISTING PROGRAM SUCH
AS CAL CAP. AND CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESS GUARANTEE
PROGRAM AND ALSO SUPPORT
INNOVATIVE NEW CROSS SECTOR
EFFORTS SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA
REBUILDING FUND. AS WELL
DIRECTLY INVESTING IN CDFI THE
PROVEN OUR ABILITY TO SERVE THE
HARD TO REACH POPULATION WHEN
GIVE THE NECESSARY RESOURCES.
PLEASE ENSURE CDFI TURN
COLLUDED IN THE PROCESS AS THE
FBI PLAN FOR CALIFORNIA
DEVELOPED THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING TOGETHER TO. HELP
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES
REBUILD AND GROW. NINE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES HELLO THIS IS
CLAUDIA BEACH AND I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF A CALIFORNIA
WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTER NETWORK
OF SIXTEEN CENTERIS NOW
SERVING TWENTY LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE- NANCY
SWIFT IS GOING TO BE SPEAKING
IN A LITTLE BIT- BUT I JUST
WANTED TO REMIND YOU OF LAST
MONTH'S PRESENTATION FROM DR
ROBERT FAIRLY. THAT THESE VERY
SMALL WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES
ARE TRULY CIRCULATING THEIR
REVENUES MORE THAN TWO TIMES IN
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. SO WHEN YOU
ARE THINKING OF ECONOMIC
INCLUSION AND ECONOMIC IN OUR
STATE'S RECOVERY AND IN YOUR
DISTRICT PLEASE BE THINKING
ABOUT WOMEN ENTREPRENEURS I'D
ALSO LIKE TO SUGGEST THAT THE
JEDI COMMITTEE HAVE A SPECIAL
HEARING SPECIFICALLY ONE
BRIEFING SPECIFICALLY ON WOMEN-
AND- DELVED INTO SOME OF THE
NUMBERS AND DATA THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED HERE AT THE- W. DC
NETWORK. THANK YOU. NINE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES AND MEMBERS OF THE
JEDI COMMITTEE THIS IS NANCY
THOUGHT SO- I AM FOLLOWING
QUALITY OF THE I'M SUBMITTING
THIS TESTIMONY AS CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S BUSINESS
CENTER NETWORK. AS CLAUDIA
MENTIONS WERE SIXTEEN CENTERS
IN TWENTY ONE LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FOURTEEN
OF THESE CENTERS RECEIVE STATE
FUNDING THROUGH THE GOBIZ
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
PROJECT. IF YOU WANT AN
INCLUSIVE ECONOMY TO EMERGE
FROM BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL
RELIEF EFFORTS AND CERTAINLY IN
CONSIDERING- TRANSFORMING
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS
WE MUST TARGET WOMEN
ENTREPRENEURS THERE ALMOST TWO
MILLION ON WOMEN ENTREPRENEURS
IN CALIFORNIA SO THAT'S ROUGHLY
HALF MOST ARE VERY SMALL SELF
EMPLOYED BRINGING CRITICAL
HOUSEHOLD INCOME. A MAJORITY OF
WOMEN OF COLOR FOR THE PAST
YEAR THE COVERT INDUSTRY
SESSION HAS BEEN AND SHE
FASHION WOMEN LOST JOBS AT A
HIGHER RATE THAN MEN BECAUSE
THEY WILL WORK IN CUSTOMER
FACING SECTORS OF THE SERVICE
ECONOMY LIKE RESTAURANTS RETAIL
EDUCATION HEALTHCARE THEY WERE
HIT FIRST AND HARDEST. BLACK
AND LYFT NEXT WOMEN WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
THIS JOB LOSSES ALSO IMPACTED
SELF EMPLOYED WOMEN THOSE
OPERATING MICRO AND SMALL
<c.green>USINESSES ESPECIALLY RESIDING</c>
IN UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES BOTH.
URBAN AND RURAL AND URBAN. W.
OF UP AND DOUBLE THE TO EARTH
STRUGGLE WOMEN AND TO STABILIZE
INSIST BUSINESSES HELP THEM GET
THE CAPITAL THAT WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING TODAY. DAVID THEIR
BUSINESSES TO ACCESS NEW
MARKETS AND CREATED DIGITAL
PRESENCE. WE'VE ALSO SEEN AN
UPTICK IN DEMAND FOR HELP IN
STARTING A NEW BUSINESS. WOMEN
ENTREPRENEURS NEED TO GENERATE
HOUSEHOLD INCOME WHILE ASSUMING
THE FAMILY CARE GIVING ROLES AS
THEY RUN THEIR BUSINESS. DEMAND
FOR BUSINESS SUPPORT SERVICES
ALSO KNOWN AS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IS BASED AT THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL AND HAS EXPECT
X. EXPONENTIALLY INCREASED IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAMS THEY RENEWED PPP LOANS
TARGETING THE SELF EMPLOYED.
NOW WE'RE SEEING A SURGE OF
APPLICATIONS FROM STE FOR MORE
P. YOU A BENEFITS FOR THE SELF
EMPLOYED. I HAVE SUBMITTED THE
FULL TESTIMONY SO I THINK I TO
SHORTEN THIS BY SAYING- WE'RE
ASKING THAT- THE STATE
LEGISLATURE PRIORITIZE THE
EXTENSION OR PERHAPS CODIFIED
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
EXPANSION GRANT PROGRAM. WE
ALSO URGE YOU TO EXPAND FUNDING
NOW TO RESPOND TO THE INCREASED
DEMAND. OF THE CARES ACT
INCREASED OUR BUDGETS BY ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS LAST YEAR BUT THIS
FUNDING ONE WIND DOWN IT'LL
TAKE LONGER THAN THAT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY HEART
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES TO
FULLY RECOVER. SO AS WE HAVE
BEEN SAYING AND AS WE CONSIDER-
OPTIONS FOR A REPOSITIONING THE
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT HE MUST
CONSIDER WOMEN ENTREPRENEURS.
IN THIS MIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH NINE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS A LOT OF SYBILLA AND
I'M THE SENIOR POLICY
COORDINATOR AT MERICA CHOPS
WITH AMERICA THE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO
MAXIMIZING OUR PUBLIC DOLLARS
TO CREATE GOOD JOBS ESPECIALLY
FOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
OUR FIRST GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CERVANTES IN THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR THOUGHTS ON
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY
AND HAS BEEN DENTAL. I'D LIKE
TO GO TO- MISTER RANEY POINTSON THE IMPORTANCE OF CREATING
AND SUSTAINING GOOD JOBS AND
RAISING INDUSTRY STANDARDS
WHILE PROVIDING ACCESS TO THESE
JOBS FOR WOMEN PEOPLE OF COLOR
DISPLACED WORKERS AND OTHERS.
WHO FACE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
TO EMPLOYMENT. THE OCT THE
MAYOR IS THE SOME ABOUT THE
STILL SB. SEVEN FOR. BILLS THE
TO RAISE JOBS DINNER ACROSS THE
TRANSFER SECTOR BY A- TO
CONVERT. PUBLIC CONTRACT THAT
AND COMPRISES BIDDERS TO
DISCLOSE THE NUMBER OF JOBS
THEY WILL CREATE A NUMBER OF
JOBS CREATED FOR THOSE FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AND
THE WAGES AND BENEFITS OF THOSE
JOBS AMONG OTHER CRITERIA WE
BELIEVE SB SETS. ARE SIX SEVEN
FOUR WILL BE INSTRUMENTAL IN
READING JOB STANDARDS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR CREATING
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA AND HELPING
PROVIDE ACCESS TO KEEP JOBS FOR
THE COMMUNITIES HAS FACED THE
BRUNT OF THIS PANDEMIC. THANK
YOU ALL SO MUCH. AND OUR LAST
COMMENT IN Q. COMES FROM MINE
TWENTY THREE NINE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING ALL OF
FIRST AND FOREMOST THAT THANK
YOU TO THE MANAGER WOMAN
SOMEONE COULD SEND THE
COMMITTEE FOR A TODAY'S
HEARING- AND FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TRUST AMENITIES
MINE. AT RADA I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF REGIONAL STEWARDSHIP FOR
CALIFORNIA FOR A STATEWIDE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION- I
WANTED TO STERN. WELL WE
INTERNET ONLY COME TO ENSURE
CAñADA ABOUT EQUITY AND
INCLUSIVITY. I WANT TO SHARE A
PROVIDED NOT OF MANY OF THE
REGIONS THAT YOU ALL ARE
SERVING OUR IN CURRENTLY
ENGAGING IN OUR REGION WIDE
STRATEGIC ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PLANS AT ADDRESSING. OKAY
BECAUSE MONEY IN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT RECOVERY- EFFORTS
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE. SAMPLE IN
THE FRESNO IN THE SALINAS
VALLEY- IN THE CENTRAL COAST
COUNTIES OF. SAN LUIS OBISPO
AND OTHERS ARE ARE FOCUSING ON
PUTTING TGETHER STRATEGIES FOR
THE REGIONAL COMMUNITIES AND
ALSO A MYSTERY ARTICLE IS THAT
WHILE CLASS AMERICANS- HE-
EQUITABLE. INCLUSIVE
DEVELOPMENT- OF J. THAT THERE
ARE- THERE IS PROSPERITY FOR
ALL THOSE INSIDE REGION'S AND-
I'M HERE TO CHANGE THE PROVIDE
SOME. AND MARK- OKAY- SOME OF
THE ONE OF SIX WHICH IS THE
SPENT BY. OUR ORGANS. BY
MEMBERS. FROM THE SENATE ONE
VALLEY- THIS. THE WILL PROVIDE-
IN THE CORNER WILL BE CALLING
THE REALIZE- GRANT. PUBLICLY
REQUEST CRITICAL IN SUPPORT
-
CONSIDER THE POINT OF THIS
WORK- INVOLVES. IT HASN'T ON
THE GROUNDS CARE IN THE CALL
CENTER PROBLEMS- AND THEN ACT
AS WELL AS STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
COME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
AGENCIES- NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL SERVICES TO
OUR COMMUNITY AND SO. JUST GIVE
AN IMPOSING REGIONS WHERE THIS
IS OCCURRING BUT THERE'S A
GROWING NUMBER OF FREE ARTICLES
IN THE STATE- THAT ARE LOOKING
TO BEGIN THIS TYPE OF WORK AND
THIS. CITY IS BUILT OF THE
TREMENDOUS COMPANY. THOSE ARE
GOOD SO- ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. AND THERE ARE NO
FOR COMMENTS IN THE AT THIS.
THANK YOU. WELL GIVEN THAT
THERE ARE FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
I WILL GO AHEAD AND CLOSE SO
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I HOPE YOU FOR
THIS HEARING TO BE A SECOND A
SOLID STEP IN DEVELOPING SOUND
ECONOMIC POLICIES THAT CREATE
JOBS AND SUPPORT ENTREPRENEURS
AND REALLY EXPAND BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES- LET ME GO AHEAD
AND- PERHAPS CLOSER COMMITTEE
NOW SAYING THAT THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL CLOSING COMMENTS- OR
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME. ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JOBS I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
EXCELLENT EXCELLENT WITNESSES
THAT WERE WITH US TODAY AND
INCLUDING THE PUBLIC FOR
PARTICIPATING. IN TODAY'S
HEARING WE ARE NOW DROWNED.